we have to begin today by reading a
statement I will
read as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuing to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the Judiciary
Committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contempor L listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available to the house in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general
court the notice for this meeting
replies out rules an RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
3600 email
HCS
l.n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are here on the meeting
assistant assisting us specifically
Jennifer G our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting will
be done by roll call
Ro we will need to start the meeting by
taking Ro call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to know
law I'll call upon the clerk
representative wer to call the
RO so representative
Gordon here in in the in the legisla
office
representative here
representative where are right here in
legislative office
building a home in Belmont
alone he we had had difficulty hearing
you representative
syvia I'm sorry I am home alone in
Belmont thank you thank you representa
I'm here in the Legislative Office
representative R I'm here in the L with
my colleagues representative silver I'm
here in my home office in Guilford only
accompanied by my three pound Yorkshire
Terrier representative
green here I'm home alone in Hudson
representative
Kell
ke
representative oh I'm here uh visiting
family in Pittsfield and I'm alone in
the
room
represent represent charia here in my
office at work in lonia
on representative
Smith representative
SMI uh I'm alone at home in Milan and
you're a little hard to hear
representative gulper speak
up representative oron I'm I'm here
alone in my u in my home in
Durham
[Music]
representative I'm here in my home
office in New Market and my husband is
in another
room representative
Chase hi I'm here in Rollins ferred in
my home my father-in-law is also in the
house representa
K hi I am uh here I am in my apartment
in Durham I'm alone in my room but there
are roommates um at other parts of the
house
[Music]
represent representative
M to our representative Langley in the
uh uh the other room at one point
attendees I think representative Langley
was
in so I think I moved her up into uh a
panelist so she should be able to speak
hopefully good
morning this is representative Langley
I'm here I'm at home in Manchester and
my husband is in and
out
representa I'm I'm present I'm here in
Portsmouth in my home office alone thank
you representative
pa uh good morning I'm in my uh home
alone thank
you hello I'm here in my home in exitor
I'm currently alone in the room but my
husband and Sons may be in between
classes
representative is that
me yes I'm sorry I can hardly hear um
this is Diane Kelly I'm home in a room
like Norm silver with a 10 pound Pap on
and uh there's family in the house but
nowhere near
me representative Smith
uh good morning I'm home um alone in
Durham and I apologize for missing the
first time round I went to try to chase
Diane from the um from the attendees to
the panel and that's when I lost
you thank you
much well welcome
everybody condu hearing this morning
and do it as best we can as we deal with
the technology here on first may I will
call upon the sponsors of course to
testify and then other people to testify
as well if you wish to ask questions
when it's time to do so please do not
hesitate to raise your hands through the
zoom
feature the first bill we'll be hearing
this morning is House Bill 248 FM
relative to the judicial retirement
plan the primary speaker of that bill is
representative ly and is representative
Lyn here and available to
speak uh yes Mr chairman I am can you
hear
me uh yes you might want to speak up
just a little bit all right I will do
that um good morning everyone um my name
is Bob Lynn um I'm the retired Chief
Justice of the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and I'm now a representative from
Windham uh thank you for allowing me to
appear today I appear um in support of
uh this uh measure which would which
proposes uh for I should emphasize right
at the beginning this would apply only
to judges appointed after uh this bill
uh becomes law assuming it assuming it
does become law um and it proposes
changes to the judicial retirement plan
um basically the the Genesis of of this
proposal which was
originally um brought before the
legislature in uh 2019 I believe and um
was was not acted upon then there there
was at least some talk of having a study
committee I I don't believe that that
actually ever
happened but there was some talk about
it at the time at anyway the Genesis of
of this proposal is that
um the simple fact is that over the long
Hall the current structure of the
judicial retirement plan is is not
sustainable at sort of re at at any kind
of reasonable cost and so this proposes
to make some changes um to uh the system
um and let me let me give you a sort of
two two points that I think are very
important to understand first one of the
pro problems which is kind of inherent I
think in the judicial retirement plan is
that it's a very small plan and compared
to the regular State Employees
Retirement System it's a tiny uh plan
there just aren't that many uh judges um
to give you another uh point which I
think kind of brings home part of the
problem is that um
the uh Mr head from the uh Attorney
Richard headed from the uh uh
Administrative Office of the courts I
believe will be here to testify and he
can give you some more recent
information but as of the as of the time
that um I prepared the initial proposal
uh back in
2019 at that time there were
58 active members of the judicial
retirement plan who were contributing to
the plan and at that time there were 66
people collecting benefits um and that
consisted of retired judges judges Who
had who had uh uh retired on a
disability uh plus the spouses of those
judges so in other words there there
were more people collecting benefits
under the judicial retirement plan than
there were people contributing uh to the
plan one of the things that the judicial
Retirement Board of Trustees um
uh sort of brought into the mix on this
was
that again I'm I'm using 2019 numbers
but that at the at the time at that
time the state's
contribution to the pension uh of every
judge was approximately
75.4% of the judge's salary so that
means that every two weeks um when the
when a judge would issue would be issued
a paycheck the state would not only pay
the the paycheck but would also have to
make an an additional contribution of
75.4% to the judicial retirement plan it
was projected at that time by Millum
that by
2035 the percentage contribution by the
state would increase to
93.3% um and it and you know and it
going out even further likely would come
to the point where where it was
essentially 100% or maybe even more um
this proposal and again I I want to
emphasize that Mr headed maybe uh one of
the things he's going to tell you I
think is that um the judicial branch is
is asking the seagull consulting firm
which was a a very well respected
consulting firm that we had uh retained
back in 2019 to give us some numbers um
that they've asked them to to provide
more recent information on this and I
think that's actually a very good idea
but seagull uh
uh told us that under the proposal that
uh that is before you now that would
reduce the um uh extent of the state's
contribution from by around from uh
projected of two 2035 from
93% to to 68% now I'm the first to admit
that 68% is still a pretty high
percentage but it's a lot better than
93% and as and as I say I think that if
if if you're going to retain a defined
benefit um retirement
plan with a with a a group that's this
small I'm not sure that you're going to
be able to do you know significantly
better than that if I can just uh U take
a couple of minutes and I'll and I'll
I'll try to be as brief as possible to
go over what um what this proposal would
do and I did send a um a memo I don't
know if if members of the committee
received that I sent it yesterday it was
a basically a copy of a of a memo that I
had sent to John forella the governor's
Council back in
2019 summarizing what this proposal
would do U but let me just sort of
briefly review it um first it would
increase the minimum retirement age for
judges um with 15 years of service it
would increase it from 60 to 62 with 10
years of service it would increase it
from
65 uh to
67 um it would change the calculation of
uh the retirement benefit right
now um a judge can retire at age 60 with
15 years of service at 70% of the
judge's last year salary or can retire
at 65 with 10 years of service at 75% of
the judge's salary this proposal would
change the formula to say that a a judge
could retire with 15 years of service at
age 62 with 10 years of service at age
67 um or with um uh seven years of
service at age 70 but the formula would
be would be based on
4% you the judge would receive a a
pension of
4% times the number of years of
service there are also um some changes
under the current system which is which
is different from the from the
retirement the regular New Hamshire
retirement system there is no allowance
made uh no differentiation made of
whether a judge takes an individual
annuity or um a joint annuity with a
spouse um and so in in in a
sense um that is sort of unfair to a
judge uh who is who was unmarried um
because there's under under most
retirement plans if if a if a judge
elects to take a joint annuity there is
there is generally some reduction
in the amount that the judge gets during
his or her lifetime to account for the
fact that the the annuity will continue
during The spouse's lifetime this would
change that to provide that there would
be such an Actuarial reduction so it
would it would um it would
equitably allow for the retirement of of
either a single or a or a married um
judge it would also change um the uh
the manner in which uh uh pensions would
be paid to a judge um who who went out
on a
disability um uh and it would CH and it
would also the other important point is
it would change the um the way the
spousal um benefit is paid right now
unlike most pension plans and I believe
the including the the regular State
retiree Pension Plan um the under normal
pension plan it uh a spouse normally
receives
50% of the benefit that the retiree was
receiving under the current judicial uh
pension plan that the the the spouse
actually receives
50% of the of the
judge's uh last year salary which is
which would is considerably more than
50% of the judges um pension so that
would that would change that it would
also provide um another I think sort of
pretty important provision is that it
would provide that a that if a judge
went out on disability the judge would
receive um 70% of the judge's last year
salary but that 70% would only apply
until the judge re reached age 70 at
which point the pension would would
revert to whatever the pension would
have been if the judge had retired at
age 70 and I I think this what what this
is designed to prevent is this kind of a
situation suppose that a judge U went on
the bench at
60 um and became disabled at
61 um well that would that would mean
that if there without this the provision
I've just discussed what that would mean
is that the judge would get 70% of his
salary or her salary for the remainder
of the judge's life whereas if the judge
had served 10 years and had then retired
at the mandatory age of 70 the judge
under this new formula would only
receive a pension of
40% so what the what the what this
proposal says is yes you you will if you
become disabled you will get the 70% of
your salary from the time of your
disability until you reach the maximum
retirement age and at that point you you
will get the pension that you would have
received um if you had if you had worked
through to the maximum retirement age um
again I think that that just is a In
fairness um that's that's a uh an
appropriate U proposal um the other
thing that it would do and I think this
is really very important under the
current retirement system for judges
once the judge has
worked a sufficient number of years so
that he would be eligible or she would
be eligible to receive the maximum pen
pension benefit which is
75% of the last year's salary the judge
is no longer required to contribute 10%
of his or her pay uh to the to uh his
his or her retirement um that's that's
been in effect since this since the
existing judicial retirement plan came
into being in
2005 and I mean from you know as someone
who who received the benefit of that
frankly it was you know it was it it was
good for the judge but I'm not sure In
fairness that it really that there
really is any reason for that provision
to exist if you're making it so this
changes that and basically says you make
10% contributions until you actually
retire um there are a few other things
um uh in this that are explained in the
memo and I know I'm I don't I know there
are other people who are interested in
speaking and and I want to make sure
that I'm I'm not sort of hogging their
time so I think that um that is sort of
the essence of what is proposed here um
I think um the one of in in addition to
the sort of financial issues that are
that are ex extent here um I think
another thing just frankly in in in in
all cander we have to say is that for
the the current plan particularly for a
shortterm judge in other words a judge
who serves let's say 10 years is really
a very very generous plan um it it
essentially says that a judge that
serves 10 years can can receive a
pension of 75% of his his or her last
year's salary that effectively it seems
to me is the pension that most people in
fact it's probably more than the pension
that most people would see receive for a
lifetime of work and so this plan
essentially says this this proposed
change look if you serve 10 years as a
judge then you should get a reasonable
pension um which under this proposal
would be 40% of this of your last year
salary but you know for example let's
suppose you become a judge at 60 and
leave at 70 well that means you've
become a judge at the you know sort of
at the tail end of your working career
and what this says is okay we will give
you a fair pension for that service that
you performed to the state very valuable
service for the last 10 years of your
working life but for the earlier part
the earlier 40 years or 35 or 45 years
years of your working life it really was
your
responsibility to to you know provide
for your pension for that portion of
your working life and it shouldn't be
the state's responsibility just because
you're a judge to sort of give you the
full pension for for 10 years of of
service and as I I happen to just speak
with uh representative Gordon um over
the weekend you know if you compare if
you compare
the judge's pension plan to a regular
state employees pension plan for you
know a regular state employee who serves
even at a high level in state government
who serves 30 years uh receives a
pension that's far less than than what a
judge would receive for 10 years of
service under the current plan under the
existing judicial retirement plan so I
think for all those reasons this this
plan makes sense as I said I want to
emphasize that
um I am I completely I I believe Mr head
is going to indicate that the judicial
branch wants to provide more information
and would need some some time to do that
um and I completely agree with that I
think we I think we I absolutely think
we want to make sure that we get this
right and if there's some you know
additional information that seagull can
provide um I I I hope the committee will
you know will will allow um that to
happen so with that I I I'll shut up and
thank you for your
attention thank
you just for the
record you I'm sorry I'm having trouble
hearing I I was explaining that this
bill would not affect me
directly it only affects perspective
retir and I do
ones uh thank you uh Mr chair and it's a
little hard to hear you
uh Mr chair so if you could speak up
generally a little little louder um
representative
Lynn I have actually have two questions
one's to the chair am I assuming that
this will go to another committee that
will look more into the uh the financial
aspects of it because I'm an H&R Block
kind of guy this will go to a second
committee that's why we're hearing the
bill okay thank you and and to uh
representative Lynn who first of all
it's a pleasure to see you here and it's
a pleasure to work with you in any
context a very brief question does this
bill as opposed to cacr 6 doeses this
Bill affect the retire mandatory
retirement age of Judges just in the in
this
bill you know thank you very much
representative buron I I want to say I I
I feel the same way about this I uh I
very much enjoyed working with you when
you're on this supreme court rules
committee and I'm delighted to be able
to have the opportunity to work with you
again in the legislature um I I think
that it it doesn't change in any way the
the age 70 limitation that all judges
must retire at age 70 that would require
the Constitutional Amendment which will
be the subject of the next um hearing
but it does it does raise the retirement
age um as I as I said right right now a
judge with 15 years of service can
retire at age 60 this would raise that
to 62 and it also raises the from 65 to
67 the um the
uh age the minimum age that a judge can
retire with 10 years of service thank
you any
question
Mr chair would it be possible for you to
unmute your computer that you're on or
does that give too much feedback with
the room because of the
feedback but I can try to speak a little
louder that would be helpful that'd be
great thank
you representative
MC thank you Mr chairman um and I too am
having trouble hearing you it's more
garbled as opposed to um the the volume
but um thank you um I wanted to ask uh
representative Lynn the question if it's
been considered that um in making these
changes that uh some um members of the
bar that are going to be appointed to
the Judiciary um would be making less in
those last few years of their um um
career than they would have in private
practice and that this might be a
disincentive for um some people to um
that are you know very qualified to join
the bar to join the Judiciary thank you
well you know no that's that's a very
good point and it's something that I
think that you know we we we rightly
need to be concerned about um I guess
what I what I would say this is my take
and I you know I have I I understand
that other people might have a different
view on this it my take on this is is
this right now what the the judicial
retirement plan is a very generous plan
I mean I I think we have to really be
honest about that it's a very generous
plan um for judges this will change that
from a very generous plan to a generous
plan in other words if under under this
um under this uh proposal for example
you right now you can attain a 70 75%
pension with 10 years of service under
this proposal you would have I believe
it's about 18 and a half years of
service that you would have to attain to
uh to get a 75% pension um but I think
it's it it's it's important to
understand that this still is a defined
benefit plan lawyers in private practice
even in big firms making a lot of money
um it's I would think it it is very rare
if if if it exists at all to have a
defined benefit pension plan I mean I
think that really is a pretty
valuable um pretty valuable asset for a
judge to have um and as I said you know
I think it's true that some some judges
uh some people who become judges
unquestionably take a a pay cut um if
they've been in private practice you
know um unquestionably they do but I
think
that I I suspect that most people who
become judges think that there are other
benefits to becoming a judge
particularly the you know the quality of
the work it it is really from my
perspective you know maybe I'm biased
because I did it for so long but it
really is tremendously worthwhile work
very rewarding I think having been in
private practice for a while I can say
you know it it is much more rewarding
than I found Private Practice to be um
putting aide the financial aspects of it
and so I think um my own sense is that
there that that there is not a
significant risk of reducing the quality
of judicial
candidates okay thank
you representative
Horan have to unmute thank you oh thank
you very much Mr chair thank you much
representative lnn um your your
successor was appointed a few days ago
and he had um in his case just a few
years of service um with the depart with
the Attorney General's office he
actually was the Attorney General so if
somebody has been a state employee in
the uh executive branch or have even the
legislative branch um are there benefits
from that affected by the fact that
they're also participating in this plan
or or is that not make or does it make
no difference what it was they were
doing before they became a a judge now
my understanding is that the plans and
again I I I I stand to be corrected on
this by Mr head if I'm wrong but I don't
think I am I think that these are really
completely separate plans so that if you
um if if for example someone were were
was a regular state employee and was to
qualify for a pension they could they
could get their pension and if they then
became a judge and then qualified for a
Judicial pension they could get their
judicial pension I think that's right um
representative Gordon if I'm if I'm
wrong on that please correct me but I
think that's
right hey
thanks if there are no more questions uh
thank you for your testimony represent
think we have a hand
up representative D
Lorenzo
lenzo uh representative Lynn I have a
question
and talking about the very generous plan
has is there any option of changing from
a defined benefit plan to a defined
contribution plan or is that totally you
know not an
option thank you no you know you that
that's an excellent question
representative D Lorenzo um you know
I going forward this is I'm expressing
purely my my this is my personal opinion
here going forward I think for both the
judicial retirement plan and for the
state employees you know retirement plan
generally I think it would make a lot of
sense for new employees to change from a
defined benefit to a defined
contribution plan but my understanding
on that and I'm not I don't profess to
be a financial expert in any way my
understanding on that is that in order
to do that it would take a huge Capital
contribution by the state
to to make up for the loss in
contributions of new employees to the
people who were you know who who are
existing employees um and I uh so I mean
unless you
unless you were going to try to make
this retroactive and I think that could
really you know there would be some real
significant fairness questions for
people um who are who are under the
existing plan so I think that in fact it
could even be some constitutional issues
on that but but I think uh um although I
think it would be a great idea to do it
for perspective future employees um I I
I I think that there are some huge
hurdles that you know it would require a
really real care really careful um uh
economic study by some experts and I
think that the bottom line might end up
being that that it would cost so much
money such a capital contribution to do
that that it it would be hard to
do thank
you I don't see any more hands being the
case thank you
well thank you and our next speaker is
Richard um thank you Mr chairman um
thank you members of the committee my
name is Richard headed I am the
legislative affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch um thank you for giving
me the opportunity to talk today as
representative Lynn uh mentioned in in
his testimony um the judicial branch has
retained the seagull group um to help us
do some uh both evaluating The Proposal
that's in representative Lynn's bill but
also to evaluate other um scenarios that
we would like to bring to the
committee's attention as as seagull
performs its work um we met with them
yesterday uh and ran through some
scenarios and they're going to put
together um a plan going forward but it
will as representative Lynn suggested
take us some time time um we do not I'm
I'm here to testify for information not
to take a position on the bill but at
the end of my um my testimony I am going
to ask if this bill could be retained in
this committee and the reason why we
think it should be retained in this
committee as opposed to going to the
second uh committee over in finance um
and be retained there is there are some
significant policy implications
associated with um whatever retirement
plan is developed in this committee you
know the the changes and tweaks that you
make to the retirement system the
judicial retirement system will impact
the type of candidates we have for the
Judiciary going forward the tweaks um
Can impact for example whether or not
it's more attractive to a younger lawyer
or an older lawyer and as a policy
matter do you want to see more
experienced older lawy ERS coming in and
joining the Judiciary or do you want
younger ones it also impacts whether or
not um you drawing um potential judges
from the public sector whether it be uh
the Attorney General's office from
public defenders from county attorney's
offices and whether or not um the
retirement system is beneficial to them
or potentially could be a financial
detriment to them um we had talked
earlier about in in the discussion with
representative Lynn those employees that
are currently in the uh State retirement
uh plan for example if those those
employees are in for nine years and and
moov to the Judiciary they've not yet
vested in the in the state retirement
system so those folks would not be
eligible for a pension out of the state
retirement system unlike if they had
gotten past 10 years uh so you know you
may be attracting a different type of
candidate for judicial nomination based
upon what the retirement plan ultimately
uh
provides one of the other things I
wanted to point out is based on the work
that seagull did back in
2018 this is not a savings that would
occur immediately you have as as
representative Lynn said this bill would
apply to new judges so you still have
have the current cost structure that
would be in existence moving forward and
really you're not going to see savings
out of this proposal for really quite
some time and really the significant
savings are not until you know 20 or 30
years out um as as the current system
judges um uh come out of the system and
the newer judges are moving into it um
so this is not a bill that is going to
impact for example the the current Bal
budget um this is a really a long-term
proposal in one we think really needs to
be considered for policy issues and
policy considerations before it moves
over to uh to
finance so at the end of the day you we
want we are asking if if this committee
would be willing to retain this bill
give us an opportunity to work with
seagull take any suggestions that this
committee may want to uh to ask and and
and give you an opportunity to ask any
questions um as as we're trying to
develop a uh a retirement plan that
works for for your ultimate goals for
the Jud judiciaries and also makes sense
financially um and with that I would be
happy to take any
questions there any
questions
thank you for your testimony um Mr head
uh I have a question and this might be
something that you know now or something
that the seagull group could look into
as part of the study but I was wondering
what the um I mean you probably do know
this but what the gender breakdown of
Judges is right now those who are active
and those who are retired and
whether this um this would we'd be able
to look at how this might affect the
draw for women candidates whose career
trajectories are often different than
men's and sometimes um progress at a
rate that's higher at the end as opposed
to sort of in the middle of their
careers it's it's a great question and
and truthly I I I have a sense of it but
I don't want to guess um off the top of
my head there is a a good mix in the
Judiciary and actually
um representative Lynn may actually know
the answer to that from his his ears as
a CJ um I don't know but I'm happy to
get that information and make sure I get
the it accurately to you um and I also
knowe that in terms of of the breakdown
of Judges you know there's a much
different perspective I think on
judicial retirement if you go from the
circuit courts to the Superior Courts to
the Supreme Court um and I think that
breakdown is important uh and is is
useful information so I I I agree we
will certainly um include that in in the
as we develop the
analysis thank
you
question okay ly do you have a brief
response yes you know what I I just
wanted to say um if it I I agree with Mr
head that if it is possible to retain
the bill at least for time in this
committee I do agree that there are
policy issues and I think we you know we
to the extent that seagull may be able
to give additional information I think
that's something that's important to
have the other point and I should have
made this earlier and I I apologize for
not the other thing that I think it it
um is is is really important um uh and
and I think supports what Mr head has
asked for is is this we we do have a
brand new Chief Justice of the super of
Supreme Court who has who has not even
been been sworn in yet and I think it it
you know it would make I I have not
discussed this with him I don't know
that any of the me you know the current
members of the court or Mr head has
discussed it with him and I think In
fairness to him it would make sense to
have him have an opportunity to you know
to take a look at this and give you his
thoughts on it as the as the incoming
head of of the judicial branch so with
that thank you thank
you anyone else
okay thank you is there are two other
people who uh who signed up in support
of the bill one is Eric graer the member
of the public and
Tomac who is a representative who also
indicated that uh he supported the bill
but would not
testify and is there anybody else who
would uh who is on the line who has
joined us today who would like to
testify seeing none we close the hearing
on
48 and call to order the hearing on cacr
6 the retirement age of Judges again the
primary and sole sponsor of the bill is
representative
Lynn and we call upon representative
Lynn to
uh thank you again Mr chair again I hope
everyone can hear me um uh so I um I'm
Bob Lynn again I'm a newly elected
representative from Windam and the
former Chief Justice of the uh Supreme
Court um and I appear here um in support
of this uh legislation which would uh
which proposes to amend the Constitution
to increase the retirement age for
judges uh from 70 to
75 um as you may
know uh part two article 78 which
contains the age limitation of 70 for
judges and also for sheriffs um has been
in the New Hampshire Constitution since
its original adoption in
1784 um a lot has changed since 1784
including as particularly relevant life
expectancy my understanding is that you
know the life expectancy in 1784 was
significantly below 70 so it was you
know it wasn't much of a limitation at
the time it was initially placed in the
Constitution um but now things are
considerably different um I had the the
honor of as my first job out of law
school of clerking for a federal judge
in Philadelphia his name was Bill
ditter he died last year at age
97 he remained in senior status he
retired but they have a a system under
the federal court federal courts where a
judge can REM can take senior status
which means you basically are required
to maintain sort of a half case load and
uh but other than that you continue to
uh get the benefits of of an active
judge he remained in senior status until
he died and I uh I would generally see
him once or twice a year he uh when I
would go to
Pennsylvania um And he as as he got
older he he definitely got more frail
physically but he was as sharp as attack
uh until the day he died he was he was
just a very very uh brilliant guy and
and just a tremendous judge
um despite that fact I I have have to
say that I do not I would not support I
know that there was a there's a proposal
in the Senate that would that would
simply amend the Constitution to remove
the age limit completely for judges I
have to say honestly I would not support
that I do think that it makes sense to
have an age limit because although judge
ditter is is you know is is sort of the
exception to the rule I suspect that um
Mo many people would feel uncomfortable
having a judge 97 years old presiding
over um their cases and that in many
cases that uncomfortableness would would
be
justified um this this is sort of an
incremental proposal it may be that 75
also is too young that maybe it should
be 80 maybe even 85 but I think that
this is an area where it makes sense to
be careful to go slowly to take thing
you know to take things in in in
increments and I think the age 75 is a
is a is an appropriate place to start uh
you know the what I use as as exhibit a
in support of this proposal is is the
person who's probably going to be the
next witness and that's Justice Carol
Convoy um who retired from the Supreme
Court at age 70 well it's got to be now
maybe uh three and a half almost four
years ago she was just an outstanding
judge
um uh completely capable of continuing
to serve um then and now um and it was
just a real tragedy that um that she was
uh that she was forced to retire at age
70 I think that I mean I've she's not
the only example um judge Dugen is
another uh one I I I hope that that I
would fall into that category also um uh
as someone who was qualified to continue
serving um but but I think that you know
the judge Convoy in particular
demonstrates um the
um the unwisdom if you will of having
the the age 70 now this proposal as you
will see and I I know uh former speaker
Donna scitec is here and uh I had a
conversation with her last night in
which she um she was uh she was uh not
in favor of one aspect of this and
that's the aspect that
um provides that under the current
proposal that if a judge wants to uh ex
extend his service be his or her service
Beyond 70 there's a process that gives
the governor and Council the opportunity
to look into the judge's qualific you
know continued qualifications to make
sure that the judge really hasn't you
know had
some uh diminution in mental capacity or
whatever
um and then the the governor and council
could hold a hearing on that if they
felt it was necessary and um they would
have a the governor and Council would
have a veto over the judge's request to
extend service to age 75 but only if the
both the governor and the majority of
the council voted to retire the judge at
70 would the judge have to retire in
other words if they if there was not
that affirm vote by V affirmative vote
by both the governor and the council the
judge could serve till 70 um I have to
repres former speaker scitec said that
she thought that was a bad idea that it
should just be uh the the age should
simply be extended to a to 75 and
frankly if you know if in a perfect
world I would agree with her I think it
uh it probably would make sense um I put
this in here frankly at the at the
suggestion of your chairman
representative Gordon who thought and I
think he
correctly um thought that um to the
extent that people had some concern
about just extending the age uh by
having this this sort of safety valve of
the governor and Council
review um it would um that would
alleviate that concern that there would
be some review um and I I you know I I
agreed with representative Gordon that
that that probably for lack of a better
term as a sort of political matter to to
uh
to assuage any concern that people might
have it made sense I discussed it with
Justice Convoy who's going to testify in
a moment she also felt it was okay but I
you know in a perfect world I would say
it probably for the reasons that uh
speaker scitech is going to tell you
about I probably would say it would be
better not to have that but to the
extent that that that having this sort
of safety valve persuades some people
who might otherwise not favor the
extension then I think um that it's
worth doing the other thing I should say
I just I I should say this just so that
there so that there's no question about
this I should emphasize that although
Justice Convoy and I would have much
preferred not to retire at age 70 I have
to emphasize that this proposal is not
about her or me uh we are both retired
by the time this could ever become a
constitutional amendment she would be
over 75 and although I would not be over
75 I'm I'm barred I now I'm now a member
of the legislature I could never serve
as a judge um so I you know this this is
not about her or me it's about future
what what happens going forward forward
and not depriving the state of people
who are very well qualified to continue
serving so for all those reasons I hope
that you will look favorably upon this
proposal thank
you my next speaker will call former
Speaker of the
House
okay now that I've unmuted myself can
you hear
me okay that's a good start uh my name
is Donna
scitech I'm a private citizen and I
didn't know whether to put whether I
would support or oppose this bill so I
put neutral and as my warm-up act
representative Lynn has told you uh I
support changing the age of retirement
for judges to
75 uh without the provision for veto by
the executive Council and the governor
let me give you a little bit of the the
reason that I'm here today because I
have a long background on this
issue uh I former chairman of the house
Judiciary Committee as uh representative
Gordon knows uh I was during the
Constitutional Convention I was the
chair of the committee on judicial
tenure so I got to look at different
models of how and how judges are
appointed and how long they stay and
there are uh a variety of ways of doing
it some states they elect their judges
periodically I can remember being in
Nevada and seeing Billboards elect judge
soand so tough on crime and I was
horrified at that because in New
Hampshire we have chosen to
insulate judges from the vagaries of
public opinion and and to allow them to
make a correct but unpopular
decision at my association with judges
uh continued after the
concon uh I was a member of the judicial
um conduct commission was part of the
Supreme Court four or five
years uh the legislature in its wisdom
established a Judicial conduct committee
that also existed
um and I chaired that for four years
until the Supreme Court said no the
legislature can't be in charge of
judicial conduct but during that time I
I had a chance to associate with with a
lot of Judges uh both active and
retired so I I have some um connection
with it I'm currently a member of the
governor's judicial selection commission
so I get a chance
to understand why people want to become
judges
um and it's it's pretty
enlightening so New Hampshire has had a
history since 1784 as representative
Lynn said of having a judge appointed
for a a specific time without the
intrusion to politics this is to allow
them to make the
correct but unpopular
decision the way this cacr is drafted to
allow a veto power by governor and
councel
introduces politics into the judicial
branch which we
have hasn't been an explicit part of the
judicial branch uh since since the the
our constitution was
established consider this so a judge who
is age
69 has a hot potato case before him he
wants to serve until he's
75 so he has to make a decision on an
issue relating to election law or
redistricting or a high-profile murder
case and he knows that members of the
executive Council may have a stake in
this and so he's has to decide for
himself or
herself how to interpret the
law I would I don't think that we should
put that pressure on a judge I think
they should have the freedom to make the
correct
decision based on the laww not on public
opinion and so I would support a cacr a
clean one that would provide for an uh
retirement age for judges to 75 without
the veto
provision and while you're in that
paragraph I think we should do away with
the limit on Sheriff's too sheriffs are
elected every two years if they're not
performing they can be voted out of
office Sheriff's are in a different
category than judges we've protected our
judges from the vagaries of public
opinion to allow them to be as impartial
as the lot of humanity will allow and so
I think having a a clean bill with just
age 75 is the way to go so I would be uh
willing to answer any questions if you
have thank your
testimony thank you your thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Israel Piedra I
represent can you hear me Mr
chairman can you hear me
okay um again representative Israel
Pedra I represent Manchester Ward I
thank you for allowing me um some time
here so I I just wanted to say a few
words um I'm I'm an attorney as well as
my post in the legislature and
um I I'm more neutral on this proposal
than anything but I just wanted to point
out a couple things that perhaps other
speakers
wouldn't be touching on um you know I I
appeared before chief justice Lynn and
and Justice Convoy when they were on the
Supreme Court I was a great honor to do
so I think they're both um excellent
jurists uh and I think if they were
still on the bench they would still be
excellent judges um that's only one part
of the equation in my mind that I don't
disagree at all with Justice chief
justice Lynn representative Lynn about
um and that's why I'm I consider myself
neutral on this bill I agree that judges
can continue to do a great job even at
age 75 so I don't think that there would
be any great harm caused by this
proposal but at the same time I don't
think it's necessary and it could have
some negative ramifications and those
are those are what I wanted to talk
about um I think it's clear that
competence is not the only reason we
have a mandatory retirement age
otherwise we would say let's let judges
serve for life and have compet
competency tests every other year once
they they reach age 70 there there has
to be some other there are other policy
reasons for having a mandatory
retirement age and in my opinion one of
those is the value in regular turnover
on the bench um and having uh older
judges more longer tenure judges retire
and younger uh newer judges take their
take their place it guards against the
judges who've been on the court
sometimes for decades um being from
becoming out of touch with the
profession or the law through no fault
of their own I should say but I think
that there can be a danger of that if
you are out of the practice of law for
that length of time and more importantly
I would say it allows for fresh
perspectives on the bench from from new
voices A diversity of
experience um
I was just looking at
some um statistics I guess or lists on
the judicial branch website and with
regard to our Superior Court which is
the the trial court of General
jurisdiction in New Hampshire where
civil and criminal jury trials take
place currently it looks like from my
reading only one quarter of Superior
Court judges are are women um there are
zero people of color on the Superior
Court uh and in fact I don't believe
that there's ever been a person of color
on the Superior Court in New Hampshire
I'm quite sure that there's never been a
person of color on the Supreme Court in
New Hampshire um and I would you know
welcome that the justices to correct me
if I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure that's
the case um currently you know there's
only one woman on the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and in my opinion that
diversity is not going to increase if we
just maintain the status
quo so although it could mean and I I I
know it would mean losing some good
honorable judges such as chief justice
Lynn and Justice Convoy I think the
turnover can also mean gaining good
honorable judges that also have
diversity of background and
experience um so there there are
benefits that that haven't been
discussed it's not just about competency
and I don't think that should be the
only part of the calculus I'll I'll also
note that New Hampshire isn't alone um
with having an age 70 retirement mandate
uh it looks Again by my
calculation around 17 states have that
requirement so New Hampshire isn't alone
there and I'll finally say that just
because a judge has to retire from the
bench doesn't mean that they have to
retire from the law or public
service you know first of all retired
judges are permitted to continue to sit
on the benches judicial referees under
current statute so an a judge that is
forced to retire at 70 can still hear
cases can still issue decisions albeit
they have to be approved by a full-time
judge and from my understanding all
retired judges have that option um
others become you know respected
mediators or return to private practice
some like our our the chairman here and
chief justice Lynn join us in the house
and we benefit greatly from their
expertise and wisdom so again with
considering all those things and then
considering the benefits that we gain
from having um fresh perspectives and a
diversity of uh experience in the
Judiciary I think that those are just
considerations that the committee should
consider as well as the points that have
been made by representative Lynn and
some other uh folks who are testifying
happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much for your
testimony
for
it's very difficult to hear the chair
I'm sorry uh we're calling upon former
Justice
con
that's is conoy we can see you but we
can't hear
you
Justice comboy uh I'm going to call on
our next speaker because we aren't able
to hear you for some reason we're going
to have to technically figure that out
and I'll call in the next speaker and
then come back to
you and the next speaker would be uh
attorney Phil
Woodberry good morning can you hear me
okay
sir yes we
can thank you very much um chairman
Gordon members of the committee um my
name is Bill Woodbury and I serve as
legislative chair
for um the New Hampshire Association for
justice uh we are an organization of 400
trial attorneys around the state
practicing in a wide variety of areas um
I am a practicing attorney in the city
of
lonia and
um uh our board has uh uh or is is in
support of this
bill uh in support of the uh of
increasing the mandatory minimum
retirement age from 70 to
75 um we do have
reservations um with respect to the uh
the governor and Council piece um as as
was uh spoken about by former speaker
scitec um we would Echo the the comments
that the Judge Lynn made um and speaker
scitec made and um you know we believe
that there are existing checks and
balances uh in the judicial system um
for evaluating whether or not judges are
qualified and that the age limit has
become
unnecessary um we do think that uh
adding the um the partisan potentially
partisan evaluation of governor and
councel is um not necessarily the best
practice here our suggestion would be
that if there is to be an evaluatory
mechanism um for a judge serving another
five years that it fall upon um the
judicial conduct committee um they are
specifically and uniquely equipped to
evaluate uh judges and judicial
performance the there as I understand an
11 member panel
um with members uh a diverse membership
nonpartisan membership and appointed
from many different areas of of the
state government you know appointed by
the the governor or the senate or the or
the speaker um and
uh We've
uh we simply believe that um you know
there there are many uh really great
very wise uh judges that unfortunately
aren't aren't able to serve anymore and
and that's very unfortunate so um we
believe that increasing the age to
75 is um uh is is a positive move um but
if there is to be an evaluation
mechanism it should fall to the judicial
conduct committee um and if uh if there
are any questions I'm very happy to
address thank you are there any
questions for wh
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for allowing me to
speak today and our last person who has
signed up this week is in fact
former
okay Jus Justice
Conboy
representative Gordon I'm sorry to
interrupt um but this is Jen I just
wanted to let you know that according to
zoom it appears that um justice comboy
has video connection but I do not see an
audio connection for
her
that sound
right I'm sorry I couldn't hear you this
Convoy
um if if yeah if you can if you can hear
us you may have to
leave your current Zoom come back in on
zoom and make sure that you activate the
audio
feature because we apparently we have
video of you but we do not have the
audio Yeah in in the meantime is there
anyone else who wishes to
speak
yes representative
silver thank you Mr chairman uh yes uh I
would like to speak in support of the uh
proposed cacr as presented uh I'd like
to remind the committee that the
appointment of Judges is made by the
governor and have to has to be approved
by the uh executive counsil already so
having them involved in this is really
part of the checks and balance of the
system we have between the three
branches of government um I've told
representative Lynn several times when
I've seen him um that I thought it was a
terrible shame that he had was aged out
a mandatory retirement age really at the
peak of his judicial career and when and
I and I believe that we we have a
situation for many of our judges as
they're approaching age 70 they're
really at the peak of their expertise
their experience their knowledge and
really we we then lose the benefit of
that uh basically the default provision
in this proposed constitutional
amendment is that uh they would continue
to age 75 unless the governor and
Council found that for whatever reason
they they should not so I think it's a
sound Bill we lose a lot of very good
judicial Talent right at the peak of
their careers and um you know I'm
certainly uh very very happy to have uh
justice and I still call him Judge Lynn
when I see him uh we're lucky to have
him in the legislature with us but we
were also very very lucky to have him on
the state supreme court and uh he should
have served on there for another five
years thank
you thank
you representative party yes I'm well I
don't want this is not the time to I
don't think it's time to speak for me to
speak to this bill there be a work
session or um executive session I did
sponsor similar they'll just eliminate
the age requirement back 10 years ago
and we fell 308 votes short of uh
getting it to the house but that was
then this was now um I do see one option
would be for justice Convoy to uh call
in call in Via zoom and we could listen
to her on the telephone I mean she has
her videos working and her
audio I think Jennifer for's uh Jen
for's analysis the technical situation
is uh the same as mine that she has a
working video connection but the audio
is not hooked
up and wor com worse we can probably
recess the hearing until such time as we
can hear from her because I think
certainly the presentation would be
incomplete without her input which is
always excellent thank you
representative
MC thank you Mr chairman I didn't know
if representative
um uh p p podio podio is isra is Israel
still available I had a question for him
um basically I wonder if some of his
concerns about
diversity um and bringing in um you know
couldn't be addressed also through the
retirement system similar to what
representative Simpson was saying that
if we made sure um that we were bringing
in new people and we could also maybe
discourage people staying so long I mean
all of those things could be looked at
couldn't they in the retirement system
bill that we heard just last half
hour represent representative Pedra you
are you still available I am can you
hear
me you like to respond to that sure I I
I didn't catch all of the last hearing
so I'm not sure I I fully uh understand
the representative's question I would
just say um yes I guess to the extent
that um we can achieve achieve turnover
in other ways then that would
essentially um work towards that goal of
achieving new voices but at the same
time I think the reality is um if judges
are able to stay on until 75 a lot of
them will stay on till 75 and I think
chief justice Lynn and the other judges
would agree with that so I'm not sure
ultimately that that will achieve the
goal that at least I have concerns about
um without that mandatory age again
although it deprives us of some
excellent judges it also gains us some
excellent judges um perhaps different
judges so that's that's my only point
there thank you and do we have Justice
comboy
that what there first of all there were
two two other people who did sign up uh
just indicating that they had an opinion
with regard to the bill one was Eric rer
and just a member of the public who
indicated that he supported he did he
did not support the bill and and Alvin C
also a member of the public who
indicated that he was in opposition to
the
bill
and and do not we don't do not so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to because
I certainly want to give Justice Convoy
former Justice Convoy the opportunity to
testify is I'm going to recess the
hearing and then we will give her uh
only her the opportunity to
testify uh before we close the hearing
in this matter so I going to recess a
hearing at this point in time on cacr 6
and and call to order the hearing on
House Bill 420 FN to the use of funds in
the drug in the drug forfeiture
[Music]
fund and the uh primary sponsor of that
bill is representative
Spain are you available to testify
it does not appear that he signed up to
testify real is a representative Ral is
a co-sponsor and has not signed
up representative Bert is a co-sponsor
does not appear to have signed up to
testify and Senator
Reagan signed up to testify
but do not
appear on the list of testimony are any
of those Representatives
available
and I don't see them any on the any of
them on the list of the
10es like that
or uh representative Rice's suggested
that she either introduced the bill that
she introduced the bill today and that
perhaps it be recess to provide the the
sponsors with the opportunity to
testify so I'm going to call upon
representative rice I just heard from
representa Spain and he didn't see a
notification so for the record I'm
representative Kim rice here to
introduce HB 420
dfn relative to the use of funds in drug
scure fund I'm sorry I will not be
taking any questions we'll save that for
people that know this bill better thank
you there are other people who
did uh sign up in this particular matter
to
testify and one being
uh Ross
Connelly a lobbyist for Americans for
Prosperity and is Ross Conley
available again I don't see him in the
list of
attendees and Joshua Albert
uh just as a member of the
public and I do see him
here Mr Albert are you have to
testify I am and I just want to make
sure that you can hear
me we can uh we can hear you thank you
chairman Gordon and uh members of the
committee my name is Josh Albert uh I'm
a lifelong New Hampshire resident and I
currently serve as a detective
Lieutenant for the narcotics unit of the
Nashville Police
Department I've been a law enforcement
about 19 years a little over and seven
of those years have been spent directly
combating the trafficking of Narcotics
within NASA and also within New England
in some positions that I've held I'm
here to testify in opposition of H Bill
on behalf of my department and also the
New Hampshire Association of the chiefs
of
police this is my first time in an
administrative role and first time
testifying before a legislative
committee so if you could bear with me
as I know you have heard uh drug asset
forfeiture bills in the
past so we are opposed to House Bill 420
if past as I read it the bill dilutes
and redirects funds that were originally
designed to to support enforcement
efforts against drug loss well I
completely understand the need and also
the importance to further fund
establishments of substance misuse
addiction recovery rehabilitation
centers programs or other
services the funds are taking these
funds away from
enforcement I think would be
counterproductive
to to the epidemic the opioid epidemic
that we've been dealing with and though
we are seeing a slight decrease in that
opioid epidemic I think we're now seeing
a Resurgence of methamphetamine and the
things that those
bring the drug forfeiture fund it's been
administered by the Attorney General's
office it served the granite state well
for many years it helps offset the cost
of conducting resource intensive drug
investigations that quite honestly
principally Target drug traffickers not
the end
user placing the fund outside of law
enforcement and allowing These funds to
be redirected other to other than law
enforcement purposes defeats the purpose
of the
fund and again it dilutes it diminishes
the fund and I think that what you would
see that would be permanent over time
the Departments that rely on the funds
that support these
investigations which result in the legal
seizures of drug traffickers profits
would no longer be able to conduct these
in investigations and therefore the
seizures of the drug profits would be
eliminated the bill would cause drug
forfeiture fund to eventually go to
zero
and who really would be burdened as the
taxpayer if they want us to still
investigate into drug
traffickers there's only a small amount
of task forces left in the state and
they're already over burdened and unders
supported and I think taking the funds
away that are intended to help hold drug
dealers accountable is only going to
lead to more drug
traffickers and just really a larger
problem so in closing I would just ask
you to find this bill inexpedient to
legislate I thank you for your
consideration I'm happy to answer any
questions I I just had one question and
that is how much money is involved on an
annual basis
would you like me to speak directly to
to nashwa Police
Department
yes so the the money varies from year to
year it very much depends on on the
investigative
success um so for example last year and
and well I don't have a specific number
if you want I I'd be happy to get that
for you in general um I believe we close
closed out the year in around a few
hundred, thank
you representative
langle thank you Mr chair and thank you
Josh for testifying this morning I
wondered um is the the drug forfeiture
money the primary source of funding um
for your task
force and so that money there wouldn't
there wouldn't be the funds for the task
force is that what you're
saying in in nashwa specifically our
narcotics unit is fully funded by
forfeiture so it's it's not other than
officer salaries uh everything else is
covered under the forcher fund and it
it's rather EX in order to maintain the
drug unit if the fund was diminished I
think that would put an incredible
burden on the taxpayers of the city of
NASA and several units are run like that
that thank you Mr
Al representative
Morgan you have to unmute yourself
representative got this thank you very
thank you very much Mr chair the uh
amount of money um addition there's
implied tradeoff in this bill between uh
treatment services and um and you know
street level uh street level enfor M
um but uh do you find you find that the
like but do you you don't but do you
find that um that the uh amount of money
even if we did put in treatment programs
would make much of a difference um on
top of like the large amount of funding
that those programs already get or you
feel you feel like this is the right way
to uh to use this money and also you
might could you tell us a little bit
more about exactly what it is you do do
with the money um I should add a I
should add that this exact same bill
came last year and I was one of uh I led
a group of 21 people who voted against
something which otherwise had uh you
know Brad bipartisan support although I
think the 21 of us were on the right
side of it that time but anyway so um
just tell us a little more about like
about how much money it is whether it
would make much of a difference add much
to what's already being allocated for
treatment in Nashville and then also
like what exactly it is that you do with
the money thank
you sure so
uh as it stands now that under the
current law um any money that is seized
and then forfeited to the state to be
managed by the attorney general and I I
believe they are here today so I I don't
want to steal their Thunder and and I'm
I'm going to speak in not as an expert
on the subject but more just in general
uh as the current L stand right now
forfeiture once adjudicated
45% is returned to any of the agencies
involved in an investigation and that is
typically split up equally 45% of the
fund is maintained by the Attorney
General's office in order to not only uh
for processing fees but to also run
their task force the remaining
10% already goes to to treatment
and then as that money that has been
seized increases uh more money is is
pushed in for those treatments So
currently in NASA the the money that we
take in and again it it varies wildly
from year to year um so it it certainly
can't be dependent
upon but we typically we contribute at
the National Police Department we
contribute to several programs um I'm
also going to be testifying on the next
bill and I get into some of the
specifics but I'm happy to share those
with you if you would like at this
point um
well representative
Sylvia yeah um thank Mr
chairman um so my question is related to
the seizures
um when you seize money there is a
profit to be made for or at least income
to be realized for the department when
you seize
drugs uh that does not produce any
um uh Revenue do you see a problem with
the incentivization of uh sorry about
the word uses the incentive to uh sees
uh cash or assets as opposed to uh drugs
so I I I have heard that argument in the
past and while I I I understand why you
make it I I think that the the funding
does so much for the individual police
departments and allows them to to do
many of the things that they otherwise
would not be able to do uh for example
the the treatment programs that I spoke
about um several here within NASA uh it
allows us to
to further and better
investigate uh those traffickers coming
into International and into New
Hampshire I mean we are in New Hampshire
it's an end State it's not going to be a
source state so uh having the resources
to expand investigations I think is
important it
allows items that wouldn't otherwise be
covered in a budget but we feel are
necessary as a police department
uh specifically training or safety
equipment uh bullet resistant
vests it'll it makes a it's a good
option uh and and it
places it does not place the burden on
the taxpayer and instead it it really
inhibits those drug traffickers it
inhibits their ability uh and and it
keeps them out of the state knowing that
we have this as a tool
thank you are there other are questions
foric and represent did I cut you
off you all set pretty much all said I
was just going to thank uh thank the
officer for giving a very excellent
brief summary of the fiscal notes so if
he ever wants to uh ever gets tired of
police work he might have a good there
might be future for with the office of
legislative Services because that was uh
much clearer than what's in the fiscal
note not that the fiscal note isn't
excellent but so I just wanted to thank
him so that's that's about all I had to
say I did have a followup but that was
pretty much my followup and I could
thank you I'd be happy I would you
believe to it if you'd like me to thank
you Mr chair thank you thank you to the
officer it appears to me that
representative may have joined
us representa Fain are you available at
this
point I am I'm sorry for being late I
did not see the notification come
through in my
email okay you feel free to
testify thank you so much uh Mr chair
and members of the committee I I am uh
here to talk about my bill as was
mentioned previously this bill uh was
submitted uh last last term and had
broad bipartisan support it did run into
some problems in Ways and Means um and
we fixed all of those problems with the
bill and have put it back in this time
with some clarification that shows uh
that direct reimbursement for costs to
these officers and to the or to any
department and to the
prosecution shall also include money
used for the drug buys and um
and for
the um time of the officers their
payroll also reasonable towing for any
forfeited vehicles and any non-personnel
operating costs so that we could explain
further that these police departments
are not going to realize a reduction in
funds to conduct their operations in
fact that's a a fallacy a lot of these
departments may actually get more from
this new bill than they were getting
previously if they're doing small
arrests it's only when the large arrest
comes in that they would be not
receiving
45% but instead receiving direct
reimbursement for all costs that they
incurred for all of their personnel both
in the arrest in the uh setup and
investigation and in the prosecution so
they will not lose any money and on
smaller amounts where say $1,000 was
confiscated there their costs incurred
are going to be more than that thousand
so they're going to get the whole amount
instead of just 45% so they're likely to
actually uh find an increase on all of
these smaller busts and only on the
larger busts would we be sending that
money on to Department of Health and
Human Services to ensure that we get
treatment and prevention for the victims
of these people committing the crimes
and and selling the
drugs we've also included now a uh a
line that allows the department to
decide not to confiscate a vehicle if
it's got a mo a market value of uh
$1,500 it's it's Exempted and if if they
want to raise that to anything higher to
exempt vehicles with a low dollar value
they don't have to go through the
process of confiscating the vehicle then
having to store it than having to sell
it and all of that they can just wave it
off and say it's not worth us
confiscating
it I'm willing to take any questions if
anyone has any any questions for
represent yes
represent thank you very much Mr chair
thank you much for the member for taking
my question
um the uh you have this trade-off here
between the uh enforcement and the
treatment um
so would is there a are those are they
actually mutually exclusive or do they
um or they uh or is one necessary or do
we need or do we need both and if so um
why do we have to take money from this
to make up for uh make up for make up
for like the insufficiency of other
sources of funds for treatment so why
not uh why not just uh raise the money
from uh from from other sources since
treatment is not a you know it's not a
politically unpopular uh it's not a
particularly unpopular program um
everybody's everybody's eager to even
though we don't have much money but
everybody's eager to like send more
money to treatment so why is why is
there why are you making this trade-off
here like are the two mutually why are
the two mutually
exclusive thank you for the question
representative uh I don't consider them
mutually exclusive in fact um to answer
your one of one part of your question
where you ask why we shouldn't raise the
money for the treatment in another way
um we do that that already but but we
are sorely lacking as you can see from
the way that we've handled this opioid
crisis and people are screaming for us
to do something more and I think it's
extremely fitting to make the person
who's been committing the crimes pay for
the recovery and prevention of his
victims by taking those assets forfeited
from the drug dealing and giving them
back to those people who were victimized
I think that that's a very wise and just
use of the funds that were
confiscated and as I mentioned when it's
a larger dollar figure or a bust I don't
think it is at all justifiable to just
give a 45% lump sum to a department even
if they did not use that much money in
the investigation the prosecution and
the arrest I think that it's much more
Equitable to say that we will ensure
that you continue your operations
running by giving you direct
reimbursement for all expenses incurred
but that when there's a windfall of
extra money we make sure that we are
funneling it towards prevention of
future addictions and to the recoveries
of those who've been afflicted by that
criminal thank you and there any other
questions for
[Music]
representative being none thank you for
your
testimony thank you Mr chair and members
of the
committee we
have Jennifer
hiin Health and Human Services you
available
hi there sorry that took a moment to get
unmuted
hello um I'm Jenny O Higgins I'm the
legislative liaison and the senior
policy analyst for the division of
behavior Health within
DHHS so thank you for your time today
chairman Gordon and members of the
committee I'm here to just provide
information on behalf of the Department
of Health and Human
Services DHHS currently has a drug
forfeiture fund account in the Bureau of
drug and alcohol services and that
funding is used for the surveillance of
the sale of tobacco and alcohol to
miners across the
state um there is potential that the
division of Behavioral Health could
expand or bolster program around
substance misuse and addiction
prevention intervention and treatment
services if proposed changes were to
allow for an increased Revenue in this
account but the amount is indeterminable
at this time and DJJ is not currently
reimburse cost of law enforcement
agencies and would need to you know
establish significant policies and
procedures for the management of such a
fund um the expansion of the
reimbursable activities would
necessitate additional staffing needs
for the Department to manage a fund like
this um so we did put in the fiscal note
worksheet the cost of a position at
DHHS if we were to manage this fund so I
just wanted to make sure to provide
information on that and I'd be happy to
take any
questions thank M
oin are there any questions from M
[Music]
oin none thank you for your testimony
thank
you and we have uh Ross
Conley hello Mr chairman can you hear me
you can excellent uh sorry about that
must have uh been missed in the attendee
list uh but I'm here now so uh thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
for holding this hearing today for the
record my name is Ross Connelly I'm the
deputy state director for Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire and on behalf
of the thousands of AFP activists across
New Hampshire I would like to voice our
support for
hp420 substance abuse and addiction are
issues that touch nearly every Granite
stator I for one grew up in Hollis and
have had multiple friends struggle with
opioid and opiate uh use usually through
no fault of their own but instead they
became addicted from prescriptions given
uh for sports Industries and and the
addiction continued from there as a
state we must be critical of our
existing policies to derive what works
and what does not work in combating
addiction reallocating monies forfeited
from Criminal drug convictions as this
bill does is a common sense step to take
approximately 50% of prisoners in the
United States are clinically addicted to
one or more drugs according to the
Federal Bureau of Prisons in Jun June
2017 there were over 175,000 total
federal prisoners in the United States
out of these prisoners over 81,000 were
incarcerated for drug offenses or
46.2% of the total federal imprisonments
in the United
States 12.9 billion could be saved if
40% of the inmates with drug offenses
were sent to treatment centers rather
than
prison treatment is the best way uh the
best Pathway to getting those struggling
with addiction into a productive life of
recovery there is no magic one that's
going to fix this problem but we should
make policy changes built around what we
know Works using a portion of the money
from the state drug forfeiture fund to
go towards treatment would set a CLE
would send a clear signal that recovery
and rehab rehabilitation are the
priorities not further doubling down on
failed policies of
imprisonment for these reasons I urge
you to support uh hp420 by recommending
a to pass and I I thank you so much for
your time and uh I'd be happy to take
any
questions okay uh representative
organ uh
yes the the actual mechanism the bill is
uh
we just turned money over to HHS so the
uh and so this is a little bit
inconsistent with afp's um position on
other issues which seems to me were
asking um HHS and they do good work but
they are be fa unelected bureaucrats as
you often remind us and they're also
there's a lot of different competing
treatment um programs and we're asking
them to um pick winners and losers so I
just wanted to uh see if you had any uh
answer as to like uh why that's an
effective uh way to support treatment to
like turn over this money to HHS with a
out a whole lot of guidance on how to uh
on how to expend it and it wouldn't also
would this not be a new government
program oh thank you for the question
representative uh our position on on
drug policy is is to look at new new
ways to address uh addiction and and uh
other criminal justice issues
surrounding addiction and and the reason
for that is that that we found the the
burden of putting someone and the
collateral consequences of taking
someone that is addicted to drugs and
only having prison as the solution uh
does not in regards to all all available
data does not actually reduce that
person's uh ability to re-enter society
and and and uh have a productive life of
recovery and uh you know doing doing so
through HHS uh just seems like the the
easiest way to immediately address that
issue and start to have uh you know
criminal money uh as representative
Spain pointed out of having money that
that was forfeited by the Dr the the
drug dealers uh and going towards uh the
recovery of the victims of of that drug
uh so I I hope that that answered your
question pretty much
thanks are there any other
questions seeing seeing none thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
Mr
chairman there there's no one else who
has signed up to
testify although there were a number of
people who indicated that they either
supported or
opposed representative Tony leas uh
Alicia
leas uh Josh Ella representative Ella
representative plazak all testified in
support oh signed up in support uh
Senator
Reagan uh signed up in
support a Nicole 40 a member of the
public signed up in
support uh Jean rusa from at the
ACLU uh signed up in support James dones
from the city of Manchester signed up in
opposition and Joseph Elbert from the
state police signed up in opposition and
Alvin C a member of the public signed up
in
support is there anyone else who wishes
to
testify seeing none I will close the
hearing on House Bill 4 420
FN is I'm just checking to see if
Justice Convoy is
still representative Gordon Justice
Convoy is connected to the meeting by
phone okay you'll see her in the
list um if you want to come back from
Recess um she'll just need to be allowed
to talk and then Justice Convoy on your
your end you'll need to unmute using
star six so I'm allowing her to talk now
here right now why don't I reopen the
hearing on
cacr
6 so that Justice Convoy would have an
opportunity to testify and we can finish
on
here so call up call upon Justice Convoy
to testify on cacr 6
good morning Mr chairman can you hear me
now hear
you great um I'm so sorry for the
technical
difficulties um but I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you by
telephone um Mr chairman and committee
meeting members my name is Caroline
Convoy I'm a retired Justice of the New
Hampshire
Supreme Court I served on the court for
eight years prior to that I served on
the superior court for 17 years I should
note that um as an aside in connection
with another bill you've heard testimony
this morning on the um ju
judicial uh pension retirement plan when
I went on the court on the Superior
Court I left Private Practice as a
partner at the mlan law firm and did in
fact take a pay
cut um I speak to you today in support
of cacr
6 in 2017 I was required by our
constitution to retire because I had
reached age 70 I did not want to
retire if uh but for the Constitutional
provision I would would still be
working uh and I am now 73 I don't mind
telling you at that time I felt
intellectually and physically capable of
continuing my work on the
court when the mandatory retirement age
was established more than 200 years ago
lifespans were decades shorter than they
are today I researched it and discovered
that the average lifespan in the late
1700s was less than 40 years
old so at that time the age of 70 surely
would have been regarded as
ancient obviously today many people are
able to work well into their
70s we are privileged in New Hampshire
to have an extraordinarily experienced
and dedicated
Judiciary unfortunately the current
retirement age leads to unnecessary loss
of invaluable judicial expertise and a
prime example is that chief justice Lynn
who was only uh in his position as chief
justice for a year and a half was
required to
retire uh he is an extremely
talented judge and um administrator and
so the loss of him only after a year and
a half was really uh sorely
felt I also note that many other states
have recognized the Merit of Judicial
Service Beyond age
70 by my last count 17 states have no
mandatory retirement age and that's
consistent with the federal
system eight states do have a retirement
age of 75 and Vermont stands alone with
a retirement mandatory retirement age of
90 I believe that cacr 6 provides a
reasonable mechanism to address concerns
that a particular judge May no longer be
fit both governor and Council have the
ability to assess the judge's Fitness
and decline to allow the judge to
continue Beyond since age
70 now I must note that I agree with
Judge Lynn I should say representative
ly Lynn in
all possible worlds I would prefer a
flat extension of the retirement age to
75 but I agree that perhaps this um sort
of compromise will appeal to people who
are worried that maybe a judge simply
doesn't have it
anymore um I also note that I appreciate
that if this amendment were to pass I
would not be able to
unretire so my concern is for the system
and the state of New Hampshire um in
general this is not a personal
um issue for me any
longer um so I believe that this will
benefit our justice system and that's
why I support it I'm happy to take any
questions are there any uh questions for
former Justice
Convoy see no questions thank you very
much for your
testimony thank you and I really do
appreciate your um allowing me to
testify um at this time after after we
had our technical problems thank you
very much we're very pleased to
have and that will close close the
hearing on cacr
6 and we will move on to House Bill 331
FN relative to a forfeiture of personal
property and we'll call upon the primary
sponsor a member of this committee
represented representative
Sylvia good morning chairman and fellow
Judiciary Committee members I'm Mike
Sylvia representing bellnap 6 the town
of Belmont I'm introducing HB 331 a bill
that will reinforce our state's criminal
asset forfeiture law I'm proud of this
committee's
work that took our civil asset
forfeiture law and added a
requirement of a conviction in most
cases this was a great step towards
assuring our citizens due process rights
were
protected we have more work to do to
extend those Protections ided in our law
the federal government has a program
dealing with civil asset forfeiture
called Equitable sharing this program
does not require a conviction as our
state law
requires Equitable sharing allows our
police to bypass the due process built
into our state
laws civil asset forfeiture has a number
of problems besides the lack of due
process it sets up perverse incentives
which has had law enforcement at times
making arrests when dealers are carrying
cash as opposed to when they are hauling
drugs drugs get destroyed after the
trial note that there is a criminal
action there but assets can be forfeited
and the cash goes to prosecutors and law
law
enforcement you will hear it's not about
the money but you can form your own
opinions the Equitable sharing program
returns 80% of the value to law
enforcement our state's criminal
forfeiture gives
45% to the attorney general's fund 45%
to the local department and 10% to
DHHS as you can see that is another
incentive to use the Equitable sharing
program The Institute for justice just
released the Third Edition of policing
for profits the abuse of civil asset
forfeiture their report states that half
of all currency forfeitures are worth
less than
$1300 at that level there is no way a
person can hire an attorney to fight to
get it
back these are not drug
kingpens this brings me to the subject
of the $100,000 leap to access Equitable
sharing in this
bill this level of seizure may be more
indicative of an organized crime
operation in this case the federal
program also brings with it the legal
resources that might be needed to
prosecute such a
case if the committee would prefer I'd
be happy to remove or adjust this
limit and finally it's the duty of
legislative bodies to fund the services
they wish to
prioritize when we incentivize or allow
executive branch agencies to seek their
own funding
we're sewing the seeds that will tend to
grow
weeds I ask for your support in
recommending autopass on HB 331 and I'd
be happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions for represent
represent representative
bur uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Sylvia you and I have
gone many rounds uh together and aart on
the issue of
forfeiture um so let me ask you pretty
much the same question I asked when this
bill came around last ter as I
understand it and I could be wrong I
understand it there's three ways let's
say um
uh assets can be forfeited there can be
a completely State operation there can
be a completely Federal operation and
there can be a
combination uh a joint operation so to
speak uh and I gather when we're talking
about uh Equitable sharing we're talking
about the last
category uh because I assume we don't do
sharing um it's a completely State uh
oper or completely Federal if that's all
true it's am I wrong in my understanding
that in a joint
operation where we're trying to decide
what money goes to the feds and what
money goes to the to the states or or or
municipalities that this is money that
is seized leg legally uh as part of a
joint operation by the feds and then the
state applies to take a share of it and
if
so doesn't this bill
essentially give
up a lot of the state's claims to money
for which the feds will be perfectly
happy to keep more of the money rather
than turning the money over to the
states that's my concern when a
d71 form is filed by the states to
collect some of that money under
Equitable sharing if this bill passes
and we don't ask for that money then the
feds just keep it is that
right I must say I think I disagree with
where your your premise
um if a an organization a police
organization within the state solely by
itself uh makes a seizure and uh I guess
we should clarify you know the
difference between seizure and
forfeiture of course is uh usually gets
a little bit muddled but uh police
officers sees things all the time uh on
the street either with or without a
warrant and that is a process that is uh
solely
uh done by them it it just takes the uh
property temporarily from uh whoever it
is so it might be a car it might be cash
it might be drugs which are obviously
Contraband um forfeiture on the other
hand is the process by which title to
assets are transferred and that is a
court process it happens after the fact
the the police do not get to uh just
grab stuff and say yep it's forfeited
and uh we're gonna go ahead and keep it
so
just to clarify that
now the Equitable sharing program allows
as I understand it you know I've looked
at it quite a bit you have too so uh
maybe uh if we disagree we'll have to
iron this out a little further but as I
understand it a a a
seizure which is a totally State um
operation there's no feds involved with
it that seizure can be adopted out to
the federal Equitable sharing program
and then that process is then um
prosecuted against the uh asset not the
person it's separate from the person
because the uh Equitable sharing program
is a civil process it's an INR process
so it's a claim against the property for
being guilty for being associated with
some uh either drug activity or money
laundering activity
so when it goes through this this uh
Federal process uh the federal
government prosecutes the case and the
uh the result of that any any funds that
come out of that uh 80% of it is uh
given to the department that uh made the
seizure you know once the the asset is
forfeited
and uh the feds retain 20% of that for
their Prosecuting so the question of the
uh joint operations and I I can't say
that I'm expert on this I'm sure we've
got folks in law enforcement that are
going to
testify the
combined uh seizures there is a lead
agency when it comes to that seizure as
I understand it there is one either
department or Special Operations unit of
some sort and that U organization is the
lead on that and that if it's a federal
operation then it's a federal um seizure
if it's a state lead on that then it's a
uh a state and local thing which can be
adopted out to the Fed so that's the way
that I understand it and I hope that
covered uh everything you need
there I could just briefly follow up
just to
clarify um and I'm looking at the at the
uh uh the manual that the uh that's the
guide to Equitable searing for State
local and tribal law enforcement
agencies and basically it
says that um in its summary section
federal law authorizes the Ag and the
Secretary of Treasury to share federally
forfeited property with participating
state and local enforcement
agencies uh the exercise of this
Authority is discretionary limited by
Statute uh the attorney general and
Secretary of the Treasury shall assure
that any property transferred to a state
or local law enforcement agency has a
value that bears a reasonable
resemblance relationship to the degree
of participation of the state or local
agency in the effort resulting in the
forfeiture uh blah blah blah and then
list the various federal agencies that
that are involved in in sending it this
seems to say that at
least that's the process by which the
state gets it from the feds do you think
that's
wrong no what it that sounds fine except
the it sounds like you're talking about
the process after it's been adopted out
to the federal government once once the
federal government gets it then they uh
then they uh forfeit the item and then
distribute the uh the proceeds that's
that's what it's I'm not not looking at
that manual myself right now all right
thank
you are there other questions for
representative
syvia
represent put your hand
down oh no that's left over
sorry and seeing no other
questions call upon our person testify
which is Ross
conell
hello again Mr chairman can you hear me
yeah excellent uh stayed around for this
one as well it's just so much fun being
on Zoom with you all uh so uh I'll
reiterate uh just thank thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
holding this hearing today again for the
record my name is Ross Connelly I'm the
deputy state director for Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire here to voice
our support for HB 331
uh in 2016 this legislature passed a
bill which strengthened the due process
rights of granite Staters the law
specifically RSA 617 colon
1-A which was passed into law by a GOP
majority in
2016 requires a conviction before
agencies can start forfeiture
proceedings unfortunately the federal
Equitable sharing loophole is being used
by agencies throughout the state to go
around state law but thankfully the
legislation before this committee would
close that Federal loophole the bill
forbids state and local law enforcement
from transferring C property to federal
agencies unless the property contains at
least $100,000 in currency effectively
stopping most cases of improper civil
asset
forfeiture this bill would protect New
Hampshire citizens property rights it
will require Granite State law
enforcement to comply with state rules
for forfeiture preventing state and
local agencies from taking assets for
their own use without criminal
proceedings or due
process a recent poll uh a recent yugov
poll conducted in September 2020 showed
that 70% of Americans oppose the
Equitable sharing program such a divide
between law enforcement policy and
public opinion is a recipe for the
distrust that we see in our criminal
justice system today across the country
this must be corrected to ensure our
justice system has the trust to carry
out its most critical business of
keeping Granite Staters safe this
legislature should continue the long
tradition of New Hampshire respecting
citizens right to doe process and pass
House Bill HB sorry House Bill
331 it makes sure our law enforcement
sticks to New Hampshire law while still
having the resources to combat the
opioid and Drug crisis with this bill
Property Owners will be safe and due
process will be restored and for those
reasons we urge the committee to move HB
331 ought to pass uh thank you for your
time again and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you Mr Conley are there
any questions from Mr
car yes repr
the
thank you uh and thank you uh Mr or
attorney Connelly as the case may be I
don't know um I have a question that my
ear
caught that this bill
apparently requires for Equitable
sharing uh cease property to have at
least $100,000 in cash or currency
and I'm wondering why the currency
aspect is required suppose there's a u a
forfeiture or
seizure uh of a million doll
yacht now that's not currency so you're
saying that that would not go into
Equitable sharing at
all uh thank you for the question
representative
uh the way
a as representative Sylvia pointed out
in his testimony uh the
$100,000 in currency would be the
highest uh uh threshold for any law such
as this across the country I believe the
next closest is New
[Music]
Mexico
sorry sorry no no worries uh uh I I
believe uh New Mexico has has current
the highest threshold which is 50,000 uh
$50,000 it may be in currency and assets
that's something we're we're certainly
willing to have a discussion on um you
know the the intent behind that is is
putting a level where you're you're
really going after the big time drug
dealers I if there is a or or large uh
big time criminals I should say uh that
that that 100,000 uh current currency
threshold is is put in place
specifically to to address organized
crime and things of that matter but I
I'd leave it to the committee whether
it'd be appropriate to lower that or
maybe adjust it to include
assets any further
questions seeing seeing none thank you
for your testimony thank you Mr chairman
next person to testify will be Joshua
Alber Mr chairman can you hear me can
wonderful chairman and members of the
committee just for the record my name is
Josh Albert and I'm a detective
Lieutenant with the nationville police
department I realize we just met so I
appreciate the opportunity to appear
again before you just so
soon I'm here to testify an opposition
of House Bill 331 on behalf of my
department and also the New Hampshire
Association of the chiefs of
police we feel the bill is unclear it it
doesn't make a lot of sense the majority
of the seizures in New Hampshire are
going to be less than
$100,000 and under the current proposed
legisl it would force us to have to use
the state forfeiture process which
returns less money to the
agency than the federal system by nearly
half and before I hear any arguments for
policing for profit I want to talk about
some of what that money goes into it
affects things like such as the guest
speaker that we bring into all the NASA
high schools to speak about being a
professional ath athlete and it
struggles with
addiction it would inhibit donations to
Bridges the Child Advocacy Center drug
courts within the state of New
Hampshire uh the Police Athletic League
and even the Nash youth Council which
screens early on youth that are at risk
for substance use
misuse if this bill is passed it would
force us to terminate all educ ation and
diversion programs currently supported
by the use of those Federal Equitable
sharing
funds under the federal guidelines we
can donate up to $25,000 to these causes
on an annual basis and we' no longer be
able to provide
that again this hits on the the note of
potentially being at risk for dissolving
the narcotics
unit because we need a certain amount of
money to maintain main this unit and
that that money
is completely other than officer
salaries the the money that is forfeited
completely runs this uh this
unit so I have submitted some written
testimony with some further facts um for
your
consideration I want to hit on a couple
points that I that I heard in discussion
um mostly relative to to due process and
I I just want to make it clear that
there's a combination of factors
where requiring a criminal conviction
well make sense is not always possible
uh people are there are times when
criminals become fugitives there are
times when criminals uh enhance their
sophistication and often putting assets
and money into third parties names so
even even though a criminal proceeding
is impossible a civil one would be and
just to clarify when we're talking about
due
process at the outset of any case the
standard of probable cause needs to be
met in order to seize any
property so we need to you really need
to show a direct link to either property
or
seizure in order to actually seize those
funds and
then there are obviously limitations um
but that forfeiture is going to be based
on the
facilitation of someone who is quote
unquote
involved um and the government must
establish a substantial connection
between the property and the crime there
are limitations on that uh I wanted to
make the point that in under the state
system if it's less than $1,000 dollar
typically the state will not seize it so
the $1,300 number that I had heard
earlier it most of the times that's not
seized if it's less than $1,000 and it
sounds like that is the case but
furthering in the due process aspect
later on relative to the forfeiture
process the government has to establish
a preponderance of the evidence that
that seized property or asset or
currency was connected to the
crime the preponderance of the evidence
standard is recognized in New Hampshire
under current statute and that's
recognized in a waste management Solid
Waste Management cases that by a perance
of the evidence property that was used
or intended for the use in violation of
the chapter under RSA 149 DM
colon4 that the Pro owner of the
property should have known that the
property was used or intended for use in
violation of the
chapter and or that property constitut
the proceeds of a violation therefore
the New Hampshire State Legislature has
acknowledged that a preponderance of the
evidence burden of proof which is the
standard in civil asset forfeiture cases
on the federal side does not violate due
process I want to make also the point in
terms of some of the language
where and and I'm hoping to explain that
investigations by and large are fluid
and ongoing just because an arrest is
made that doesn't mean that the
investigation is necessarily over and in
fact you could stumble upon certain
facts and
circumstances that would lead you into a
larger
investigation and really that's what we
do in in the narcotics field especially
as I made the point during the last bill
that New Hampshire is an end State we're
not a source state so we start at the
end and we work it
backwards with those investigations
being fluid often time our federal
partners are called
upon in order to assist with the
investigation assist by offering
resources and that allows us to
then ultimately use those resources to
to attack those Source States
uh as far as the
distribution that representative Burch
had mentioned uh I have worked in a t in
a federal Task Force and and I can speak
to that
that there are several local members who
typically work in task
forces and when it comes time to divvy
up that 80% if uh based on the federal
agency
determination that can be separated
evenly it can be separated by who put in
the most work as oftentimes Task Force
officers are working on separate
investigations in closing I I just want
to speak to House Bill 420 and House
Bill 331 if they were to pass I think
that they would directly lead to the
demise of this narcotics unit and our
ability to prosecute drug traffickers
and keep our citizens safe I would ask
that you find this bill expedient to
legislate and I thank you for your
consideration I'm happy to answer any
questions representative Smith did you
have a
question yes I did Mr chair thank you
very much and um Mr Albert thank you so
much for appearing before us um I have a
question and if the chair permits
perhaps a
followup um when you say that passage of
this
these bills the one before us right now
um uh 331 and the one that we heard uh
previous that it would uh it
would uh cause the end of your drug
program um can you tell me how much of
your total
funds come from these
sources So when you say drug program are
you referring to the narcotics unit or
you referring to the programs that we
donate money
to um I want you to tell me what I'm
referring to because I was
unclear um what you said sounded just
awful for those of us who care uh to
have
strong uh drug prevention and support
programs in this state so if you were
not to have these funds what what of
your programs would be affected I'm
sorry Mr chair I hope you don't mind
that I
responded I have similar question go
ahead thank
you so can you tell me exactly what
programs would be um would be eliminated
if these bills were to
pass so the
the there are several different programs
so
um Bridges is is a program that um
offers advocacy for victims of uh
domestic violence and other other
victims of violence the nsha youth
council is a a program that screens
juveniles who've been arrested and
and
often in that screening process it's
learned that uh either alcohol or sub
some type of substance misuse is on
board um and a percentage they take the
money and it offers them the ability to
to screen a percentage of of the people
that come in uh the Child Advocacy
Center is is an
institution uh that assist s with any
real crime against a child um and they
offer their services uh I believe one of
the other programs I I spoke about was
the Chris Haron project uh he's a a
local former uh really outstanding
athlete uh all the while in his career
suffering from
uh uh substance misuse so he comes in
and he speaks with the high school
students
uh here in the city and it's really just
a wonderful presentation so all of those
things all those donations all of those
particular programs obviously cost a
great deal of money but we can use these
the the funding in general be it the
state or or through the federal
Equitable sharing program that money is
is returned into those programs we also
donate money to the drug court here at
the Hillsboro County south
um so those are the programs I'm
speaking of and in is relative to the
narcotics unit as I've stated this unit
is run solely on the the funds from
Equitable sharing and forfeiture those
cover things uh like equipment training
for the officers and
detectives phones
vehicles uh any any bills that come up
and really reducing the amount of of
money as in 420 I I had a couple
questions on that and I I I realized we
probably can't Circle back to that but
both
bills affect will be affect our
day-to-day operations in this unit I'm
hoping I answered your questions
representative uh could I follow up Mr
chair you certainly may thank you very
much um uh and thank you very much for
that information um as to the um the
programs you mened Child Advocacy Center
uh Bridges youth Council whatever um can
you tell me um how much what percentage
or how how many dollars come from these
sources uh to the those programs and
what percentage they are of the total
budgets of those
programs I believe I believe the
National Youth Council it's a just under
50% uh the total dollar amount that can
be donated uh on an annual basis is is
$25,000 uh relative to the percentage of
forfeiture that that varies so much from
year to year that that I I couldn't
speak to
to the percentage of forfeiture that it
is going back because if there's a year
where
$50,000 is seized and forfeited to back
to the department well then I guess 50%
of forfeiture would go towards those
programs but again that that number is
I'd
be pure purely speculating and I I I I
just don't think it's feasible to to
know a amount that a percentage that it
would be may may I follow
up and I know this is not this is the
Judiciary Committee not the finance
committee and I understand that and I
don't expect you to have all the numbers
the reason for my questioning is I'm
wondering um how the city of nashwa
itself um values these programs um has
the city made a determination that the
only re reason they would uh or the only
way they would support these programs is
if funds come in from sources other than
um the city budget um and that these
would be considered um extraneous uh
programs otherwise in terms of what the
city of NASA has determined for its
policy in this
area well I
I think that the the city
wholeheartedly supports the opposition
of these bills because the the mayor of
the city has signed on and and signed on
in opposition of both
bills I won't I won't belabor it um Mr
chairman I think you know what I would
say next thank you very much for letting
me speak certainly welcome is there
anybody else who has
questions
seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there uh there were a
number of people who signed up either in
support or in opposition to the bill uh
there's no one else that signed up in
advance place to testify but
representative Tony leakas Alicia leas
representative Josh
yella OAC representative Norm Silber on
our committee uh all and representative
Judy Aaron all signed up in support of
the
bill in opposition James dones from the
city of Manchester signed up in
opposition uh Joseph Ebert from the
state police signed up in
opposition
and there's also Alvin C who was just a
member of the public who signed up uh in
support of the
bill is there anybody else who wishes to
testify happens to be
attendees oh seeing no one then I'll
close the hearing on House Bill
331 and we'll adjourn the committee
until one
o'clock thank you everybody thanks for
everybody's patience today with us
learning the
technology thank you members if you
would U mute your video and audio your
welcome to stay on the call it will um
continue through the Lunch Period I'm
just going to share a notice um for the
benefit of the
public thank
[Music]
you iil you no
problem
for
so
and I'm
muted
good
[Music]
hello
yes thank you
for she we asked her that question she
said that that killed everything so
that's not what I was told like when you
come in in the morning that is
running wow
so okay I'm just telling you yeah what
what was brought up
yesterday and uh so I asked her and she
said
such a hike from over
there where were you are you were just
in my office over at the oh office
house
good afternoon Judiciary Committee just
a reminder for represent mlan to unmute
the room when you guys are ready to
begin want to un it now yes
please can ask her to make me a co-host
again I can help
out and Jen could you make uh represent
MCL a co-host again will'll do and it
looks like it is unmuted and ready to
go yeah after the first couple years
charte was
really Jen this is Mike Sylvia um
representative Huff didn't receive a
link as he managed to get
in um is he planning to
speak I'm not sure uh what the order is
of bills but he has one coming up I
think okay I do not see him in the list
if you could um you said he's a
representative Huff oh I'm sorry he's uh
he'll be on at two o'clock okay okay uh
2:32 sorry
okay we'll call the house Judiciary
Committee back to
order our next item of business is a
hearing on House Bill
481 and I believe that the prime sponsor
is representative the Lorenzo and would
you like to provide testimony
today uh yes I would uh Mr
chairman
May proceed
okay well thank you Mr chairman and host
Judiciary Committee members I am
representative Charlotte D Lorenzo
representing Rockingham 17 the towns of
newfields and New
Market I introduce HB
481 which establishes the office of the
right to know edsman and makes an
appropriation for that position
transparency between citizens and the
government that serves them is a
Hallmark of democracy and its purest
form RSA chapter 91a is New Hampshire's
right to know or Freedom of Information
statute here in New Hampshire our
citizens and our press have been
continually blocked from seeking
information from public bodies recently
I've noticed an uptick in New Hampshire
newspaper articles
that end with the reporting reporter
writing we have filed a freedom of
information request with the public
agency involved and the request has been
either delayed or
denied now a little bit of history on
this bill this bill was the result of a
2017 right to know study commission that
was charged with finding a cheaper
faster way to resolve right to no
disputes between citizens and public
bodies since the initial introduction of
this
bill it has been introduced uh several
times and it's called the ombudsman's
bill the basics of the bill have been
refined over the years in 2020 SB 696 a
similar bill was passed by the Senate
but due to the covid-19 shut down the
bill was not passed on to the house for
legislation this bill has bipartisan
support and we have received letters of
support from many stakeholders including
the New Hampshire press
Association the New Hampshire Secretary
of State's office has offered space in
the SOS office along with furnishings
and telephone and internet
service thank you for hearing my
testimony and with this I pass the torch
to folks who have signed up to speak on
the bill thank you Mr
chairman there any questions for the
representative yes representative
M thank you
representative my question would the
decision of the um have the same for of
law as a decision coming out of the
court so would the municipal be bound by
would
decision if I heard your question
correctly you're asking me if the acts
of the AR edsman or decision of the
edsman would have um the force of Law
and no no it would
not however there is a route
to deal with the legality of the edsman
decision and that would be to Superior
Court
any further questions for represent
yenzo
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um I'm trying to find a
way to get to yes on this bill so my
question is a fairly basic one and maybe
you can explain it to me because I'm I'm
missing something here let's say let's
say I'm at loggerheads with the town of
West Milan on getting some information
right current route is I go to Superior
Court cost me money in time that's right
as best I can tell from this
bill I could then go to an
ombudsman and if the town is still
resistant I'm back in Superior Court
four months later spending the same
amount of money four months later so or
five months or whatever it is so where
is the savings to me if I'm at
loggerheads with the town it's just an
extra step then
that if if Superior Court starts the
whole thing over again denovo which it
does uh where's the
savings well the savings is would be
in the citizen not having to make the
initial investment to get on the docket
of superior court and and also the
superior court docket is pretty busy um
and
so the time savings would be by running
the issue by the um edsman and having
them work on
it okay thank you you're welcome thank
you thank you for your
question yes represent McAn so if I
could just follow up then on represent
vers question was there any thought
given to the fact that maybe the
legislation should uh have the force of
law why why was why was that left out in
other words that they come forth they
can bring a decision it doesn't have the
force of law was there a reason for
having it that way
repres I really don't know the answer to
that question but I can speculate that
at this point um the bill is
it's new um it has a sunset Clause if
it's not working um and so I think that
eventually in time it could have the
force of legislation if if the
legislature found that um desirable but
right now it
doesn't thank you representative rice
thank you Mr chairman um I really like
the idea of this bill my concern is so
in in one part it says to um compel
interviews with
parties but that again it has no force
to be able to make someone come in and
have an interview is that
correct so it seems to me that we're
just buting heads again the same way we
have been trying to get these these
right to know
requests um done
right um I'm not sure that I'm following
you could you talk about um people being
are being compelled to meet with the
edsman it says in the bill it says
compel interviews with the parties it
says compel timely delivery of Records
within a period not less
than I I'm asking you what what
Authority would they have to actually
compel them to come is it just a request
or is there any rule of law that can
bring that for them to come
in I think I'm sorry go on that's it
okay well I see it as um once the
citizen agrees to go into um sort of
like arbitration with the hitsman
then I think that in a in a spirit of
cooperation then they would need to you
know follow through with producing the
documents or whatever the utsman
request follow Mr chairman and I
understand that the person that has
filed the request would probably be more
than happy to go in and call interviews
I'm referring to the other side of the
co oh I see out the right you know you
know not giving out
information how are they going to compel
them to an interview when we can't even
compel them to comply with the right to
no
request I really don't know the answer
to your question maybe one of our
Witnesses would be able to help you with
that thank
you there
any do you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh representative for taking my
question um because this is going to be
very new and the barrier to entry is
going to be much
lower um what what kind of Provisions or
what uh what are we thinking about in
terms of uh overwhelming the Ombudsman
and uh the size of the office that's
going to be needed what what kind of
Staffing have uh has there been any
Research into uh into those uh
particular issues well we actually spoke
with the um edsman for the state of
Maine and she has been in office for
about five or six years and so um
initially when the main edsman position
was first initiated um there was a
flurry of request but
um in her view they were
manageable and and at this point after a
number of years they've slowed down
quite a bit and then as far as Staffing
and um office
space the secretary of state has offered
space in his
building um and the bill
does ask for an appropriation for the
salary so we think we've got it got it
knocked there thank
you representative wford you have a
question no Mr chairman I just had a
comment to
representative any uh is there anyone
else who has a question for
representative D
Lorenzo seeing
anyone thank you very much Mr
chairman yeah was
that representative Langley did you have
a question
or I think you're muted I did thank you
thank you Mr chair representa D Lorenzo
I was going back to U people talking
about the the um the impact of law or
the enforcement capacity this doesn't
have in in terms of law is it the
expectations the Ombudsman would really
um negotiate with the parties that are
involved so that there's a a settlement
that occurs before people get to feeling
like they have to go to Superior Court
and that the the um resolution of
whatever the issues are uh occur
beforehand that is the desire that's the
why the bill was designed so yes thank
you
any other
questions seeing none uh representative
langle you also are a co-sponsor would
you like to testify on the
bill uh I I think I'm offet Mr chair
thank
you and I think representative Smith you
you are a
CO are you interested in testifying uh
no thank you uh very much Mr
chair we have other people who have
requested to testify we have Cordell
Johnson good afternoon uh Mr chairman
and committee members
uh you can hear me I assume we can okay
uh thank you I'm Cordell Johnston uh
government Affairs Council for the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association and uh the municipal
Association I guess I would say
cautiously supports this bill um we
agree with the goal of it which is to
make resolution of right to
noaw uh issues faster and cheaper we
hope that it will be beneficial not only
for those requesting uh making right to
no requests or complaints but also for
municipalities that um
frequently are not sure how they should
respond because the law is sometimes
unclear and if they can get those issues
resolved uh in a uh in a less formal
process uh that should be beneficial to
everyone um I I I say we cautiously
support it because uh as representative
dorenzo said it it's a new process and
so no one can really be sure exactly how
it will play out a lot of it will depend
on the the competence and The
credibility of whoever the Ombudsman
is uh and so we we like the idea that it
has a Sunset date so that it can be
reviewed after a couple of years to see
how it's
working
um like to comment on on a couple of the
questions that were asked repres chch
asked where are the savings if the if
the Ombudsman ombudsman's decision can
be appealed to Superior Court and that
that's a good point you could end up
starting all over but uh I think what
we're hoping is that the
edsman will as I said be competent and
credible and uh that that when he or she
issues a decision that the parties will
see that the decision make sense and
most of the time will not appeal to
appeal to Superior Court so that they
won't have to incur those costs uh if if
if the Ombudsman is no good then then
yeah you'll end up in Superior Court a
lot but we're hoping that uh that that
that will not be the case so ideally
those those appeals would be avoided in
most cases sure there are going to be
complicated or contentious cases that
will end up in Superior Court uh no
matter what but I think that's always
the case and then I think it was
representative mlan asked a question
about whether the ombudsman's decision
would have the force of Law and I guess
not exact ly sure
um uh what what was meant by that but
certainly the ombudsman's decision would
be binding on the parties if it's not
appealed on page three um line 27 it
says the ombudsman's final rulings which
are not appealed may be registered in
the Superior Court as judgments and
enforcable through contempt of court so
if the Ombudsman orders a town to
disclose some records and and the town
doesn't appeal and doesn't disclose the
records then the town's in trouble
um what it would not be is um the the
ombudsman's decisions would not have any
precedential value they would not be
binding in other cases they would they
would only bind the parties to that
particular case so uh it's just a
there's a distinction
there and I don't think I have anything
more to say but I'd be happy to answer
questions any
questions
John seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you David
sad
can you hear me this is this is David
sad you can hear me okay thank
you my name is David sad I live in
rumney New Hampshire and I'm also
president of right to know New Hampshire
I ask you to support this
bill right to know New Hampshire
received citizen complaints from across
the state at as we are a
resource citizens turn to when they feel
their public officials may be violating
the right to no law for each of the last
four years we have averaged over 50
inquiries which include complaints and
requests for
assistance some of the complaints we
received were one a public body was not
following the governor's executive order
for remote electronic meetings two a
superintendent quoted six months to fill
a right to no request for
records three a town was not properly
posting meeting
notices four a school board made a
decision outside of a
meeting five a conservation committee
refused to provide access to records of
proo proposed conservation
easements each of these complaints could
be addressed by an
ombudsman however without an ombudsman
they will most likely not be addressed
as the individuals does not have the
time M or expertise to seek redress of
their
grievance law in 2017 with the passage
of House Bill
178 um it established a commission to
study processes to resolve right to no
complaints after two months of hearings
across represent representation of
stakeholders unanimously agreed that a
citizen needs a faster cheaper grievance
process establishing an independent
Ombudsman was the recommendation after
considering a number of
Alternatives I was one of the 13 members
on that study commission I was also one
of the members tasked with writing the
study commission's final report which I
hope all of you will read
uh and I contributed to the drafting of
this
bill in New Hampshire the deck is
stacked against the citizen while on
paper it appears that the right to no
law provides an open and transparent
government enforcement of this law Falls
squarely on the back of the individual
citizen who has the financial and
emotional Capital to take their
government to court to enforce their
right to know most citizens simply do
not have the time or money to fight for
themselves and their fellow
citizens public officials in some cases
know this and use this barrier to their
advantage as they violate the rights of
all
citizens for each right to no petition
filed in court there are many more
violations which are not pursued by
citizens because they cannot afford to
do
so and when a citizen does go to court
public officials use the Deep Pockets of
taxpayer funding to fight against the
very taxpayers who are paying their
legal bills this bill creates a lowcost
speedy incredible and impartial
grievance resolution
process um I would like to um respond to
a question that was put forth previously
about you know where are the savings
with the on budsman this has come up a
number of times um it has been very
difficult we have tried as an
organization to um identify the cost
that have incurred by various public
agencies uh as they um uh are incurring
court costs and legal costs uh dealing
with right to no issues
unfortunately uh the response we've
received from many uh public bodies is
that uh they don't keep track of that
information separately their legal
resources that they have at their
disposal um don't break out uh the the
time or cost for right to know issues
versus non-ri to know issues I can say
from my experience as president of right
to know New Hampshire and dealing with
uh complaints that have come into our
organization over the last uh five plus
years that um there are many complaints
that never make it to
court uh and that will continue to be
the case until we establish some form of
independent uh Arbiter that uh allows
the citizen at minimal cost to file uh
and get resolution of a right to no
grievance thank you very much for your
time thank you and are there questions
for Mr
sad
represent representative
syia thank you Mr chairman thank you you
Mr sad for taking my question um it
seems to me that the
difficulties with uh enforcing right to
know as it is now is a weakness in the
right to no
law why would
we build a new government
institution uh to fix a government
problem well within the right to no law
as it currently exists there is a
section on
remedies and uh those remedies uh are
available to the citizen however those
remedies require that the citizen file a
petition uh in Superior Court and as
I've mentioned that's a very timec
consuming costly um proposition for the
average citizen the bill for the
Ombudsman has included in its language
um the um ability for the Ombudsman to
make a ruling on any uh right to know
complaint and can order any of the
remedies that are outlined in that
section um so the Ombudsman can make uh
an order uh and a ruling to offer up the
same
remedies that the citizen would get by
filing a petition in court um
additionally
um if
the if the citizen or the public body um
chose to appeal the ombudsman's decision
to court which uh again it we we hope
will be few instances of that happening
but if they do the the citizen has the
added benefit of not having to pay a
filing
fee um to do so and second that the
budman's ruling would be um attached to
the petition uh and the judge would have
to address the issues that are raised by
the Ombudsman um during the ruling that
they would make uh as part of that court
process um so uh I think there's a
there's not really uh while there's been
some argument in past that the remedy
section of the law could be improved
upon um and I think that that's a bill
for a future time um the benefit is that
they would be able to uh get the same
remedies that they can get by going to
court followup Mr
chair go ahead so you spoke of this
Ombudsman as being an impartial
arbitrator so to speak um when I look at
things I see citizens against the
government and uh this is just another
government entity that the citizen is uh
going up against and that makes it two
to one do you not
agree um
I
uh I I I agree that that possibility
exists and I think there was a lot of
effort that we put into when we had the
study commission one of the topics that
came up is where was this office of
edsman going to be located there were
some that suggested the Department of
Justice For example uh we had a lot of
discussions at that time about where
should it be located and it was decided
the secretary of state would provide the
least uh be the location that would
offer up the least conflict of interest
um where the citizens may not get you
know a fair Shake um I think your
concerns there's some um you know that
it's it's a valid concern um but I would
not um uh I would I would like to be
optimistic in the thought that this is
going to take us a long way towards the
goal of making a grievance process you
know fast easy and cheap for the
citizens thank you representative
bur thank you Mr chair and thank you as
always uh Mr sad you educate me year
after year and I appreciate that
um a question that was asked earlier I
want to uh revisit and that is the uh
the process
involves compulsion of bringing
in uh
mandatorily uh the other side documents
and the like they use the word compel
timely delivery of Records there's no
limitation on what records can be um
requested whether they're relevant
records whether somebody might oppose
them they might be confidential they
might have juvenile information who
knows uh and then compel interviews with
the parties how do you Vision that
compulsion being done uh by subpoena
court order um by how are you thinking
about uh compelling citizens to come
in uh as I as I think you know is having
read the um the bill um it does not
provide the level of details around what
will be done to compel and again this is
an area we had discussions during the
commission uh about that topic um the
the key here is that um both parties um
are going to be compelled to provide the
on budsman with the necessary
information so that they can so that uh
that uh Ombudsman can can make the the
proper ruling of course um if they if
either side chooses not to
comply um then we also have in the bill
language that allows the on budsman to
draw a
negative inference from A party's
failure to participate and comply with
the
orders Rie process so the resolution for
the Ombudsman although they
can't um Force asai to
compel uh and with the the process if
they fail to
um uh participate and comply with the
ombudsman's orders then the um budsman
will draw a negative inference and make
a ruling based upon that negative
inference and I think that's a very fair
thing to do uh if either the citizen who
had made the complaint or the public
body which is uh the subject of the
complaint doesn't wanna um help resolve
that problem um then that can be taken
as a negative um
inference if if I could just briefly
follow up uh what what if the town says
you want document number 23 and it from
our perspective uh under law that's a
privileged document or a confidential
document and it will cause um a
violation of state law to turn it over
or or some other grounds there's no way
in this to appeal I mean either you you
uh refuse to turn it over and get a
negative inference or you're forced to
turn over something that may be improper
to turn over um do you think that needs
a little more
work uh no I don't um and again there's
language in the bill that addresses that
um first of all we have excluded from uh
uh uh the ability of a citizen to file a
right to no request to gain access to
any documents which are confidential so
even though they're provided to the
ombudsman the Ombudsman has to maintain
any confidentiality will review those
documents um sort of uh in camera like a
court would um and then upon completion
of their review uh and their ruling they
will return those documents to the uh
the public body that provided them and
while they're in the possession of the
Ombudsman uh no one uh they do not have
to be provided to anyone else under RSA
91a that inclusion is in this
bill all right thank
you representative
Morgan thank you very much Mr chair Mike
um I don't know whether you've answered
to this to but how is the uh theam
buzzin himself or herself and her her
office would have to be subed the right
to no law so what what happens if
somebody BS a right to know request
about the EMB budman's office Andor I
assume sometimes two people will file
peti the um budsman and turned them down
and then that'll become like one more
issue in the long running dispute that
you know needs to be subed the right to
know so we find out why the udman really
made the decision they made so what how
does how's the
utsman and is or her office covered by
91a themselves in case there's a right
to know dispute involving their
office um well the hearings that the
Ombudsman would hold if they are needed
um are subject to
91a and uh the records um with the
exception that I mentioned in the in in
answering the previous question um
General uh records of the on budsman
themselves such as complaints that were
filed and the like would be available
under
91a uh so you know it is possible people
could request access to that information
um I think that's like any government
agency uh you know we need that openness
and transparency and so I think that's a
good thing but yet we've built in the
language to make sure that any
confidential um exempt records that
would not normally be disclosed under
91a can't in in in some other manner be
disclosed through the ombudsman
follow Mr chair um the other issue is
what happens can I ask to follow up Mr
chair go go ahead repres oh thank you
very much Mr chair so Mr sad what
also maybe there's some general
Provisions that would apply but I don't
see anything here about what to do if
Deon budman has a conflict of interest
say if they've worked in the past for
the public body if that's a subject of
the uh of the request so obviously
whatever the decision they made
situation like that would obvious be at
least colored by at least the suspicion
that they were favoring their former
employer so um is there any what
provision is there for an ombudsman to
step aside and have an acting Ombudsman
when
needed uh there's nothing in the the
language to um that provides for you
know a second or or tertiary person to
fill in for that
role um
of course if the citizen felt that the
ruling by the
Ombudsman um was unfair for reasons due
to such as a conflict of interest um
they still have preserved in this bill
the full ability to go to court so um
you know that options still exists and
that could be used in the situation
where a citizen felt that maybe there
was a conflict of interest so the
Ombudsman ruling was not fair um and
that's how they would deal with
that okay yeah thank thank you very much
Mr chair and thank you Mr sad so that
that's all the questions I have for Mr
sad any other questions for
Mr seeing none thank you Mr sad thank
you very much for your testimony you're
welcome and we do
that
complete does Carla
gy hi this is Carla can you hear me good
hi guys uh good afternoon honorable
committee members thank you for uh
giving me the opportunity to testify
here today I'm here to ask you um I'm
the former Republican state Senate
candidate for District 20 I live in
Manchester I'm an attorney by training
and I serve on several nonprofit boards
including right to know New Hampshire
we're a nonpartisan Statewide citizens
Coalition that works to improve
government transparency and
accountability as you guys just heard
David said uh testified in support of
this bill as well so I'm testifying in
my personal capacity as a citizen um I
think everyone here an agreement that
this sounds like a generally pretty good
idea uh New Hampshire generally does not
rank as well as one would expect in
terms of uh public integrity and public
access to information so I think we
understand there's a problem and we're
trying to find a
solution um I think the utzman I have to
honestly say I was not a fan when we
started out with this I think much like
uh representative Sylvia I am skeptical
when we grow government to try and solve
a problem that already exists but I've
come around to support this primarily
for several reasons all the great
reasons David just explained um in terms
of what we think this bill can do
obviously making things cheaper faster
more accessible all that good stuff but
also I think um it it it because of the
sunset close if we figure out you know a
couple of years down the line that this
was not a great idea or or that it is
indeed just creating more Hoops for a
citizen to jump through then we can come
back and we can tweak it I was really
actually encouraged to hear that
statement about the main um bootsman
because I suspect something similar will
happen here I did want to address
something that um Cordell Johnson
brought up you know I think with the
municipalities a lot of times what's
happening with right to know requests
it's not so much that there's this
pitting of of the citizen against the
agency I think a lot of times it
genuinely is people don't know what the
right answer is anymore they don't know
what they can disclose they're not sure
what they're supposed to redact and when
people are uncertain about things what
tends to happen is as we all know if
you're a parent you know it's just easy
to say no and then to say because I said
so so I think what the utzman can create
here is an
opportunity to actually help train the
mun municipalities to instead of having
that sort of fears Fear Factor of I
don't know so I'm going to say no I
think over a course of a couple of years
we're going to see a decline in these
requests because everyone's kind of
going to know what they're supposed to
do how they're supposed to redact what's
important to redact and what we should
be giving to our citizens under New
Hampshire's very beautiful
constitutional requirement that requires
that our government should be open
accessible transparent and respons
to the people and so I feel like this is
going to create that opportunity to
actually be responsive to the people
um I know there are costs involved as
someone who's a small limited government
kind of gal I'm not psyched about that
but again I think if we start to compare
what we are spending on right to no
cases and I think we're going to see an
acceleration of that um from a cost
benefit anal analysis over time this is
going to actually help us um I've been
testifying on this bill for at least a
couple of years that hearing and the
task force took place in
2017 that means we're looking at four or
five years down the line I really want
to encourage you to take this seriously
move us in the right direction help us
establish a cheap fast easy streamlined
credible and impartial way to ensure
that our government remains open
accessible and account of to us um I'm
happy to take any questions you may
have thank you representing
syia thank you Miss Garrick for taking
my
question how long would it take for you
to list the government agencies that
went away and I understand there is a
sunset clause on this but how long would
that
take not very probably zero
thank you Mr
chair are there any other
questions thank you for your testimony G
thank you and we also have who signed up
appears to have her hand raised is
Harriet former representative Harriet
Caden
it says I have to unmute I'm not
familiar with this we can hear you thank
you honorable committee for listening to
me this very strange
way I want to um say to representative
Mike
Sylvia well it isn't in my
responsibility to be able to make
committees go away but maybe if the
legislature did follow the Sunshine Bill
they had they would start looking at
what was necessary and what wasn't
again that isn't something we've been
able to do back
to the bill we're
on I would like to point out that the
cost of having an on
budsman will be minimal in comparison to
the cost to the community's
lawyers the courts having to be open for
hearings letters and such sent by them
and the sheriff's department delivering
rits uh I know myself in the several
right to know cases I have done as
prosay the average cost would be around
$750 to me and to my community around
5,000 the Comm the utsman would allow
for the community person who said no to
a right to no request to appear and
explain why they felt they couldn't give
the information versus the communities
having to hire a lawyer to go to court
which is most often the
answer
secondly um the utsman
office uh secretary of State Bill
Gardner tells me he's had four or five
that has said they would be willing to
work
free as an ombudsman that would have to
be taken into consideration on whether
that would be allowed or
not if there is an on budsman conflict
of
interest I assume we could set up a uh
alternate for them to hear the case I
don't see how it would be hard but I
think the bill could have that addition
to it if we've got other free
services I have 50 years of experience
in right to
know I find that the majority of right
to know problems occur because the
53,000 plus employees of
municipalities cities counties
do not know their right to know if you
look at the training done by
nhma it averages about 1,500 of those
53,000 plus employees that are members
of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association I have written to over 20
state
agencies asking what they estimate they
expend on right to no
requests the one that shocked me the
most was the Attorney General's office
who must defend a state agency such as
in Hawkins versus Health and Human
Services or ATV and Dees there are
several others but the Department of
Transportation told me their average
cost well they told me the actual cost
19 for 2016 17 18 and
19 and they had a cost of between 26,000
and 31,000 each
year so the state could incur savings by
having this the Shocker was the Attorney
General's office who told me they don't
spend any cost well since the state law
requires the Attorney General's office
to defend
agencies and I know they have I would
assume they have spent money as in
Hawkins
versus uh the State Health and Human
Services or ATV versus
Dees
um I think what I'd like to say the most
is the legislature is charged by the
Constitution with serving the citizens
of the state through
representative
elections we send people to the
legislature to represent the
citizens to look
at putting a law in place such as right
to know and then leaving it to the
citizens to
enforce I believe has done half the job
of it
interpreting article 8 of the new
Hampshire
Constitution I did write up testimony
which if I can find in my computer where
I went to I will send on to
you well thank you for your testimony
today thank you hopefully this year you
will pass
it any questions for Miss Katie
can you speak a little louder I'm having
a hard time hearing and I've tried to
increase the volume and I've got it as
high as I can probably
just so I will try
to the are there any questions
for Miss
Katie seeing none thank
you thank
you I don't see see
any we
do Richard head Richard
head um thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record my name is Richard HED I'm the
government Affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch uh and I apologize I
must have messed up my registration to
speak this this afternoon um uh on
behalf of the judicial branch we do not
take a position on this bill um but
simply wanted to make a recommendation
that the
appeal um from the EMB budsman be
directly to the Supreme Court rather
than through the superior court with a
trial
denovo um it seemed just in terms of
resources and time that the goal was to
speed up the process so if the party
elects to go to the EMB budsman which is
the process to elect to the beginning
either Superior Court or um
budsman that if there's an appeal that
be rather than Superior Court be to the
Supreme
Court um and that was my only point and
I'd be happy to take any questions thank
you yes representative walker uh so if
if we chose to put the appeal directly
to the Supreme Court we do that with no
fing fees as we have with Superior
Court obviously that's a a legislative
uh right now there is a filing fee for
appeal to Supreme Court
um so that at least under current law
would
apply uh there is no
no
I represent do you want to ask the
question again I'm sorry
Mr it sounds like no to
Me Maybe I misunderstood at least right
now the appeal would be to the spe Court
which under the under the current law
would be has would have no filing fee uh
an appeal from the Superior Court to the
Supreme Court would still have a filing
fee under the current law um and I'm not
I'm not making a recommendation one way
or the other relative to the filing fee
so we would have to put in
legislation so uh if I can just
ask if if in fact you did away with a
denovo hearing in the Superior Court in
effect the findings of the armsburg men
would be final because the Supreme Court
could only review it as a matter of law
is that correct that's correct they
wouldn't unless the unless there was no
basis for a finding a fact the findings
of fact would would presumably um the
ombudsman's findings of fact would be
would be in place and it would be
appealed on rulings of law unless there
was just no factual basis in the record
for the EMB budsman factual
findings so so if I could just follow up
that would seem that that would make the
AMS budman's
rulings more effective in terms of of uh
having an impact on the parties
involved yeah I don't think I I I'm not
going to express I don't have an opinion
on that per se um as it as under the
current language of the bill if it's not
appealed the UDS men's decision is is
filed in the superior court and can be
enforced fully um if it was a direct
appeal to the Supreme Court it it would
essentially follow the rules of of any
sort of normal agency appeal
um where the the findings in of the
administrative body um remain in place
and thus there's no uh factual basis
there's nothing to support it on the
record um so then it would be a legal
appeal that's
correct okay are there other questions
for Mr
head representative
Bur
yes my question was basically the same
as representative Gordon's if I is it my
understanding uh Mr head that uh uh a
procedure at the uh uh ombudsman's level
with no rules of evidence no rules of
procedure um an uncertain question about
compelling testimony and people that
that would lock in the uh the factual
portion of the uh proceeding and uh both
sides would be so to speak stuck with it
again I would just caveat as you know
with any most administrative agencies do
not follow the the uh rules the The
Rules of Evidence or procedure of
superior court so it' be a similar
appeal to as to any administrative
agency uh be based on the record below
there is a limited ability to review the
factual record as I said before um to
make sure it was supported by the record
but if supported by the record then it's
largely a an appeal of the legal
issues thank
you any other questions for attorney
head well we're not going to let her ask
a question but we call up on her again
when they're done with representative
head I've seeing no other
questions thank you Mr chairman uh and
just I apologize I have to jump off for
another hearing but um happy to to
follow up with any
questions thank you thank you Mr
chairman okay and is there I see no
one representative former representative
Katie you you have a comment you'd like
to add
briefly keep forgetting to unmute I
would like to just add that I talked
with the utsman in Maine and she said
that the first year of the law she had
requests and she wined them down down to
about 25
hearings based on very simple
misunderstandings of what they wanted or
needed okay and since then each year she
has about
25 um requests for
hearing and they've gone very well she
finds It's very
effective okay thank thank you for
adding that's all thank you the
uh uh just in terms of other people who
did sign up uh Senator GAA signed up in
support several people signed up in
support including representative wer
representative
plazak
uh Jean Roa from the ACLU Cindy
rosenwall Heather Koo Cynthia muso Jan
Schmid Lewis khit
Paul Martin Eric
ratham uh and David Taylor there's one
person who signed up in opposition and
that was a Julie
Gilman uh from who indicated she's an
elected official in
ex and if
there's no other testimony then I'll
declare the hearing on House Bill 481
closed and open the hearing on House
Bill
[Music]
232 this is a
bill excuse me Bill relative to
non-public sessions under the right to
no
law and the primary sponsor is
representative Greg Huff and
we will call upon representative Huff to
address his
bill Mr chairman can you hear me we can
hear you now okay thank you um and thank
you committee members my name is Greg
Huff I represent belnap County District
3 Laconia
I'm the primary sponsor of HB uh
232 I've uh submitted to the chair and
the members a document with information
supporting the bill um and I asked that
the chair U have that document uh
entered into the permanent
record
okay so as far as the bill goes um I'll
tell you how it came about um along uh
the summer campaigning in my town or
city of
lonia what happened
was uh our city council moved to uh
purchase a property it was
a uh Church property um in near the
center of town and uh they paid I want
to say about
1.25 million for it uh with zero public
zero public input nobody knew uh that it
had happened
until um somebody had noticed it at the
registry of
deeds uh when confronted about uh how
this went down the city council
um our city council uh every year or
every couple years when they uh convene
much like the House of Representatives
down in conquered uh they adopt rules in
among the rules uh one of them is for
non-public session on under
91a uh 91a they uh cited for the reason
for them not needing to uh give any
notice at all
um the problem with
this is that also in the budget and this
is just a little side note in the budget
that they had they uh created a thing
called
XYZ um it was
to put in a bond of believe around s or
$800,000 that Bond uh was not earmarked
for any
purpose we later found out what the
purpose was it was to buy that property
so they not only knew well in advance
that they were going to purchase the
property or at least make an offer on it
they also kept that from the public to
add insult to injury and this is all in
the supporting documents that I I
provided um
they also uh the city manager had sent a
memo to the city council including the
mayor instructing them not to mention or
speak of the
XYZ uh at all to the public so you can
imagine the backlash that the folks here
in town uh had over that they were not
uh very happy about
it this is not the only time this has
happened I also have one other Link in
there um this uh sort of has also
happened once before uh with another
property in town to the tune of around
$350,000 that's also in there for you
folks to to check out um to get to the
bill itself what I noticed when I read
through it and the the section that they
were talking about that they cited
specifically for their ability to uh to
do this is uh is uh what my bill
directly
addresses a common phrase or word that's
used throughout 91a is the word
consideration uh if you'll notice
throughout uh 91a it's used I want to
say I believe nine times and in uh all
the other instances it's the standard
use of the word uh the word for you know
considering to purchase something
considering uh uh maybe uh to talk about
something considering firing and hiring
folks uh all of these things are kind of
in there it occurred to me from my
background as a real estate broker years
ago that consideration means money it
means uh the transfer of or promise of
uh something of
value so it doesn't mean in this
particular instance that they can talk
or discuss or decide what they're going
to do it just gives them the shield to
actually when they've already decided or
discussed it um in public
that they can then go behind closed
doors in a in a p non-public session and
decide what kind of offer uh what kind
of uh uh money they may or may not want
to to decide to use so that's the bill
in a in a nutshell and um I'd be happy
to answer any questions the committee
may have at this
time questions for
representative
also have testimony
from
Representative no not representative
from Dave
Karen good afternoon can you hear me
now
okay thank you for uh the opportunity to
comment and voice my opposition to H
Bill HB
232 as the bill is currently written uh
my name is Dave Karen I am the Town
Administrator for the town of dairy and
I've been serving uh local governments
in the Hampshire for 40 years now you
know there are currently few
opportunities to empty non-public
session pursuant to the right to no law
which is good as both local and state
governments in New Hampshire
strive to maintain account accessibility
and
transparency one of the current
exemptions which is the ability to
consider the acquisition sale or lease
of real or personal property has served
our citizens well and has allowed public
bodies to conduct its business as
directed by the legislative body in the
most efficient and coste effective
manner the proposed language in the bill
is confusing to me and I suspect others
and warrants clarification if the intent
of the bill is to require that any
binding offers or execution of a
purchase and sales agreement be made by
the governing body in Open Session then
the intent should be made clear our
understanding of the law is that this
public process is currently required and
one which we follow rewriting the
proposed amendment to clearly State this
intent would
suffice my my concern with the current
language is its
interpretation the Lang language could
be construed that a public body could
only enter non-public session after it
has had a public discussion on the
desirability to acquire a specific
property and has agreed to proceed with
acquisition this interpretation is
fraught with risk in our opinion first
the M discussion along with the attended
benefits of acquisition often results in
a higher asking price which is contrary
to the public good second during these
public discussions a seller may B may
better understand the motivations of the
buyer which may have not been considered
previously by the seller again
potentially leading to higher costs due
process in government takes time it has
occurred in the Hampshire and
experienced and witnessed by me that a
third party has learned of a potential
acquisition by a unit of government and
has taken advantage of that due process
period by purchasing the property by
themselves and not making it available
for uh the uh public body to further
consider the purchase and lastly my main
concern is to is the attempt to separate
discussions regarding the advisability
of acquisition versus
negotiations these activities are
inextricably linked as a public body
considers price the discussion and
variably winds back to the advantages of
acquisition with additional discussions
on cost and benefits we all if we as we
have all learned in Our Lives plaintiffs
who disagree with a lawful action resort
to attack in the process and this
language as currently proposed is right
for conflict again thank you for the
opportunity to offer comment on HB 232
and I urge the committee to either
clarify or reaffirm that a public vote
is necessary to bind the unit of
government when acquiring property or to
alternately vote this bill as
inexpedient to legislate thank you for
your time
are there questions for
mren don't see any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony person who signed up to tesy
is Cordell
[Music]
Johnson thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman and committee members um again
Cordell Johnston representing the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association I I think I may have signed
up as neutral um but we are opposed to
the bill as written and uh Miss Dave
Karen who just spoke I think pretty much
said what I would say um I think the
bill goes too far uh I was not aware of
the situation that the sponsor
described um but if if the if if an
entire discussion and transaction from
beginning to end
happens uh
entirely outside of public session then
I think there then I think there is a
problem
there I don't I don't want to comment on
a on a situation where I'm not familiar
with the facts but um but obviously
certainly the final decision to to
purchase uh property ought to be ought
to be at least uh documented in public
session not in not in non-public but I
think the bill goes too far in saying
that you can't have a
discussion uh as to whether to proceed
with an acquisition sale or lease of
personal property in nonpublic session
there are situations that again I think
as Mr Karen described where um just
discussing the need for for buying a
particular piece of property if you dis
if you discuss that in public
session um that could indicate to the
owner of the
property that uh this is a that this is
considered a highly valuable piece of
property and give them a um an incentive
to take a very strong position uh in any
negotiations so I think I think the
statues statute as it currently reads uh
if it is
followed uh scrupulously covers the
problem it allows non-public discussion
only if uh the discussion would likely
benefit a party or parties whose
interests are adverse to those of the
general
Community I I think that is adequate to
uh protect uh the public interest and at
the same time uh protect the uh the
public body's ability to negotiate from
a position of strength so I think
um we would suggest that the language of
the statute be left as it is because I
think it I think it addresses the
situation pretty
well got questions for Mr Johnson
Yes W thank you Mr
chairman Mr
Johnson said raise the price of the
property isn't that in opposition to the
interest of the public and so isn't that
always the
case I'm sorry I could only hear a
little bit uh I don't know whether it's
possible to move the microphone closer
to
you it seems to me that if the public
part is considering buying
property and discussion in the in Open
Session will drive up the price of that
property for Harden the negotiating
position of the potential
sell then in every transaction
would create the situation that
nonpublic would it
not I think I think at some point every
situation would would lead to would
would lead to a need to to go into
non-public session I I don't think every
situation would start that way um if
it's the if it's simply a discussion
that the town
uh needs to uh
is uh looking for property for a new
police
station um I don't think that by itself
comes within the current exemption for
non-public
session uh there but there does come a
point and you know it's it's not a hard
and fast line but there does come a
point where uh where the
discussions where the discussions need
to be in nonpublic to uh to not give the
party on the other side um an unfair an
unfair advantage and and I I I I can't
tell you exactly where that is it's a
it's a facts and circumstances situation
unfortunately any other questions for Mr
Johnston thank you for your testimony
thank you
and yes representative Lorenzo thank you
Mr shair Mr shair I have a question for
representative Huff I had my hand up but
I don't think you saw me I did not I'm
sorry about that I apologize thank you
representative H would you like to would
you be willing to take a question
yes go ahead
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you um representative Huff for
taking my question you know in your
testimony you mentioned um at least two
instances in which
um there was a
cloud over the sale and acquisition of a
property and you said that you thought
that the RSA 91a uh was
violated
um is this
problem Universal in New
Hampshire I have come across um
anecdotal evidence um I've I've talked
to other
Representatives that uh say that it
similar circumstances have happened in
their town for example one in um
sington um the difference was is that
the consideration was actually an
exchange of property um again this is
anecdotal and I don't have any any
backup for that um apparently the story
was um they wanted oddly enough a police
station and they traded that property
for a different property for a new
police station um I also heard of
something uh down in Nashville but I was
not able to actually run that one
down thank you Mr chairman follow
up okay so
um and secondly I'm wondering if there
is enough if you have any documented
instances of this
issue so that it's large enough to
become a new
statute um that's a great question and
thank you uh I think a million two to
the people of lonia is enough and as
somebody pointed out in their testimony
uh preceding the question um he used the
term if if it is followed uh
well it hasn't been and when one person
or group can figure out that they can
circumvent it then others will follow um
the purpose and uh Mr chairman if I may
expound on this a little bit go ahead
thank you
um the the um
characterization
of the two pre uhe uh previous uh uh
speakers
isn't quite exactly right um if if you
actually read it it's the bill um that
I'm proposing says this sub paragraph
shall not apply to General discussion or
deliberation whether to proceed with an
acquisition um they certainly absolutely
can get behind closed doors to discuss
the finances um and also the idea of it
tainting
uh one way or another or influencing one
way or another the reality is in real
estate it's a an agreement between two
people if a seller puts out a a property
or it says it's uh available a buyer can
can offer the seller can always say uh
well I want more or the buyer can say
okay or I'm not going to pay it it's a
mutual thing it's it's free market and I
would just like to end uh my statement
real quick here um with the preamble to
91a
because I think this really hits to to
the point of this whole thing openness
in the conduct of public business is
essential to a uh Democratic Society the
purpose of this chapter is to ensure
both the greatest possible public access
to the actions discussions and records
of all public bodies and their
accountability to the people and and
with that that's that's all I have folks
thank you
thank you so much for the
question
representative
here there this would be better yes I
got a two-part question my first one I
guess is direct
specific at represent Huff the other is
more might be for the chair it's about
uh just the documentation that sent to
us but the uh so you're talking about
the city council and versus the people
but and certainly City council's not
everybody supports everything the city
council does but isn't the city council
actually acting on behalf of the people
of lonia who elected them or do you see
them as uh entire apart from the people
so I'm just not sure uh I clarify what
you meant by that I mean certainly um I
don't know anything think I have no
opinion whether this real estate deal is
a good good good idea or not but you
know City councils and town councils you
have to buy property all the time from
private sector so you're what sort of
Distinction were you making though
between the people and the city council
and the city
but thank you fa thank you
representative um I understand your
question um it's not a it's not a a US
versus them uh scenario the reality is
uh once they're elected they are
entrusted to uh to carry out the the
business uh at hand and as such this
will not hamper that literally uh
whether the people whether the folks who
are afforded something a deal or against
it the city council or whatever uh body
that's elected to to handle the business
is going to choose to do what it is that
they're going to do at the end of the
day all this does is is allow the folk
what it is that's going on before it's
already done and that isn't that the
entire heart of
uh
91a I suppose I suppose to Mr chairman
my second question um so representative
Huff sent a sent us a uh letter which
presumably want to be in the permanent
record and guess in the past it's been
kind of hard to find these permanent
records but thanks to circumstan we uh
you Mak some changes how we handle it so
should represent Huff or somebody um
obtain actual copies of the links to
three news articles and a letter to the
editor from The lonia Daily Sun which
right now is not behind a pay wall um
all these articles are still available
but would it would it be some value in
having res Huffer somebody submit actual
like copies of the Articles like show
what the link led to at the time of of
this hearing um because in the past the
past we would have expected him bring in
a print out of the articles but that's
uh you know that's not practical because
he's uh remotely and actually the same
issue could apply to the supposedly the
document the registry of deeds but that
those are expensive and difficult to
obtain so I wouldn't fault anyone for
just I not just you know taking it
Taking the word of the person can count
the register Deeds I'm not necessarily
the committee needs to see the register
Deeds documents but it would be simple
at this time to preserve these articles
as they are now because they might not
be that way you know the next time we
have a related Bill and probably in the
future it's going to be easier to get
hold of these Bill files they're not
going to be just hidden either on the
second or the fourth floor depending on
how long it's been since the hearing and
really GNA be easier to find in the
future and people are probably going to
rely on them more so representative hu
is able to send that to the committee as
a whole he wishes to do so be
happy and if he's unable to do that and
he wants to send it to me then I can
forward it
on sounds thanks sounds yeah sounds good
to me thanks Mr chair I know I'm making
more work for our we're making more work
for ourselves and we're overwhelmed as
it is but yeah that that sounds like a
good idea thank you I agree yes Mr chair
yes I I I can um I can download and get
copies of those um if you would like and
I can either mail them in or or um drop
them off when I come in for my committee
uh later in the week think that if you
look at the link where you signed up to
testify it will have a means of forward
testimony as well and that might be your
most convenient way without
cop
okay
and is there anybody else who wishes to
testify this Katie can you make it
breath hi sorry this stupid unmute comes
up
after uh the the difference between
towns and cities buying L land in
comparison to the state is having worked
as an appraiser fori way we appraised
the land then make an offer that we want
to buy it versus a town or city they
hide it behind
doors and in the long run if they really
want only a certain piece
they have the right of eminent domain
and so in my opinion there should be no
exemption for the buying and
selling that's all thank you thank
you there were other people who did
indicate either their support or
opposition to the
bill uh there were a number of people
who supported David sad Carla gy Lewis p
Eric rathor representative
plazak representative
silver and Alvin Alvin C there were two
people who signed up in opposition who
indicated that they did not intend to
speak one was Julie Gilman indicated she
was an elected official from exor and
Christina
Barrett uh who represents the New
Hampshire school boards
Association and if there's no further
testimony then we'll close the hearing
on House Bill
232 we next hearing is scheduled
for one of one of the things that we
could consider
doing uh as opposed to the prior session
where you couldn't have any executive
session uh on the same day that we heard
a
bill we under the current circumstances
we've agreed to do that but I as I
indicated when we met before I wouldn't
do that unless I felt that was the
appropriate thing to do but I was
wondering if the committee would be
interested with regard to the first bill
that we heard today where there seemed
to be General agreement even among the
sponsors with regard to retaining the
bill
whether you the committee might consider
going into executive session to consider
that possibility and I I
might first inquire of Representative
Smith if she feels that that would be
appropriate
today thank you um U Mr chairman yes I
think given the circumstances um of the
uh univers
belief that this was a bill that um had
Merit but would require more work I
would think that if you wanted to
entertain a motion to
retain um House Bill 248 that that would
be um appropriate at this
time and I'm presuming that we have to
actually move to go into executive
session yes Mr chair
and
so and was was that a formal motion to
do so Mr chair I would if you would
entertain a motion I would move that the
uh Judiciary Committee go into executive
session at this
time second okay it's been seconded by
representative
rice and moved by representative Smith
to go into executive session
and that requires a roll call vote and
I'll call upon the clerk to take the
rooll got the clerk by
surprise she
already Mr chair I have a quick question
yes uh given that we're about to go into
executive session just a reminder that
everybody is supposed to be on video
live correct
yes apologize for that and that is in
executive session if you wish to vote
you need to
be or
here thank you Mr chair thank you I
appreciate
that
right
apologize again to the clerk for
catching him by
surprise so the motion is to go to
Executive session represented the
plan
yes
representative mlan is not
visible well he in he in the
room he should be on the uh in the big
picture
yeah representative
syia he's not
VIs
representative
yes representative Alexander
yes representative R yes
representative stelber
yes
green
yes representative Kelly
is oh I'm sorry did you say
representative
Kelly
so where are we with representative Kell
I don't think she's visible is
she I think represented T May respond
yes so I'm sorry I thought you said
t
w
representative
now yes
I'm
here
representative
yes representative
Smith
yes
B
yes representative oron
yes
yes representative D Lorenzo
yes representative Chase
yes yes
representative
Langley
yes
representative representative
MC
yes representative
P not
visible representative
Simpson
yes Mr chairman yes
yes nothing uh the vote being in the
affirmative we the motion passes bill
will be
[Music]
retained
um
M Mr chair if you would now that we have
um agreed to go into executive session
would you entertain a motion um uh to um
retain House Bill
248 I I
would thank you very much for your
courtesy Mr chair thank you and it was
that a motion uh yes I would so move
second and who was that the seconded
silver
and
okay again the motion is to retain to
recommend retention of the
bill and
clerical call
roll what did we just
do he contain House Bill
[Music]
yes representative
here is
visible can I assume that an affirmative
vote does not put one on a special uh
committee to listen to this retain bill
in the
summer
if so I vote in the
affirmative
affirmative representative Alexander
yes representative rice
yes representative silver
yes representative
green yes
representative Kelly not here
yes
representative
Smith
yes where's the
Wisteria representative
Oregon
yes
representative lenzo
representa
[Music]
yes
yes representative Langley yes
representative MC B
yes representa
page page represent
page
did you get a vote for represent bures
bur representative
Burch we can see
you
yes and and and the chair
votes representative Simpson yes
yes chair
vot V
yes so I V
to vot being 20 to zero the motion
passes and we uh recommended that the
bill be
repain
and that be on the consent
calendar I think
that
not
up okay now we need to v v
to
do I we leave executive session okay
it's been moved by representative rice
that we exit executive session and is
that seconded yes seconded by
representative
Alexander without objection we can do
that without a
vote off without exception do anybody
want to make an
exception being none we've left
executive session and we're preparing
for our next
[Music]
bill so Mr chairman yes who assigned
number 420 to a drug forfeiture
bill
thank happened
before why couldn't you do that
TOs and I think
[Music]
that's so
we start in three minutes for those that
are
those who are interested in such things
the Biden Administration said today it
would not um renew any contracts for
private prisons at the federal
level
uh
yeah we'll call a hearing to order on
House Bill 566 relative to cealing
records in nonpublic
session
[Music]
the the primary sponsor is
representative yella and is
representative yella
available yes thank you uh Mr chairman
and thank you
uh members of the committee
for uh hearing my testimony today and uh
thank you for the previous
uh sponsor of HB 232 for giving me a
great setup um for my bill this my bill
is
um trying to address uh the the the
right to know law is trying to balance
the Public's right to know uh what
happens in non-public meetings with the
harm that such knowledge could impose on
individuals and the community as a whole
and only allows the minutes to be kept
secret under specific circumstances and
states the Public's right to know may
only be withheld until the circumstances
no longer apply that made them conclude
the damage would outweigh the benefits
of keeping that information from the
public but the law does not set up a
method for the boards to
re-evaluate the circumstances that might
change that cost benefit analysis over
time it instead relies on the boards to
have the wherewithal to go back and
reconsider an issue that is not
currently before the board this is not
happening as non-public meetings one
sealed are often never looked at
again I would like to see the boards
address whether or not is still
appropriate
that the public be kept in the dark
about what happened in these nonpublic
sessions as the law seems to imply that
they should however we do not create the
rules or incentives to do that um and I
propose that we ask these boards um to
take a look at these minutes
um on a yearly basis is my suggestion
and if they don't then the minutes would
automatically be unsealed however when I
proposed uh a bill to that effect last
year there was cons um expressed some
concerns with something being unvert
unsealed and so it was Pro proposed to
only address a sealing of non-public
meetings held to to discuss the
acquisition sale or lease of real
personal property as the damage from
such information accidentally being
released is just to the risk of that
single deal and uh something
which is
circumstances uh
can be changed over time and likely to
the um the reasons for sealing such
minutes would likely no longer apply you
know in the one to three years after
that meeting took place so I um was
happy to hear that the right to know New
Hampshire supports my
idea uh and but they proposed uh uh an
amendment to my to my
uh proposed language which I'm sure you
will hear about and um their proposal
was essentially to just automatically
unseal these these minutes once the
contract is
finalized and I have a couple of issues
with with that proposal language and so
um in the interest of getting my my
comments out there uh so that you don't
have to come back to me my my first
issue is that is that this is kind of a
uh test of the concept of resealing
minutes to allow the sealing of minutes
to
um or allowing the ceiling of minutes to
expire and expand that concept if it
works in this test case so changing the
direction of the bill
would
more make this a one-off solution and
not really um help the legislature
address
the bigger issue of of encouraging
boards to re-evaluate the ceiling of
minutes
regularly and whether or not that
sealing of minutes is still approp roate
and secondly um if the committee decides
that it would like to address the
acquisition of property Alone by
adopting the proposed amendment I think
that the language has a flaw that the
proposal assumes the purchase occurs and
does not open up the minute um if the
deal ends up falling
through and so with those concerns I
hope that the uh committee supports the
leg legislation as written
and I would be happy to take any
questions are there questions for
representa I don't see any questions
this point time so thank you for your
testimony
absolutely thank you next speaker would
be David
sad
you should
do can you hear
us you need to
unmute
are you there Mr sad uh yes I am can you
hear me
now okay thank you sorry for that
confusion um my name is David sad for
the record I live in Romney New
Hampshire and I am president of right to
know New
Hampshire um I ask you to support this
bill with an amendment um as was
mentioned by rep Yella
um and I'll get to those details in a
moment um minutes and decisions reached
in non-public sessions used to discuss
the acquisition sale or lease of
property are often sealed because the
release of minutes to the public could
render the proposed action
ineffective in this case the information
may be withheld until the circumstances
that would render the proposed action
ineffective no longer apply this is the
current law as it stands
today once a contractual commitment to
acquire sell or lease property has been
signed by all parties the proposed
action has been finalized upon contract
signing the proposed action has become
effective and binding on all parties so
the circumstances for sealing the
minutes no longer applies and public
release of the minutes can no
longer consider uh be considered as
rendering the proposed action
ineffective uh since the preamble to the
right to no law states that we have the
uh requirement for an open government
which is accessible and accountable to
the people uh we should interpret the
existing law that the release of the
minutes should happen after contract
finalization uh but often this does not
happen I believe the law needs to be
clarified to make this requirement
clear uh as such we are suggesting an
amendment to the
language such that it would read uh that
an exception shall apply to those
minutes generated from subparagraph
2D which may be unsealed at any time but
which will automatically be unsealed
after closing or contract
finalization to rep's point uh we could
also add
termination as well to cover that
condition um I do I do appreciate rep
y's um sort of uh overarching goal which
is to address the problem that does
exist around uh minutes getting
sealed and then those minutes remaining
sealed long after the
circumstances no longer apply this is a
ongoing problem with the law it is
currently written um since his uh bill
is really addressing only the
acquisition uh uh in purchase sale of
property
exemption um the amended language that
uh we're suggesting kind of fits with
that loan um exemption the other thing
thing that I would note is that back in
2015 uh we drafted a bill which was
passed HB
108 which uh caused the language uh in
this section to be
updated uh to require that the
vote to seal the minutes is done in a
public session and again that's current
law
today uh in this amendment it's talking
about automatically
unsealing uh the
records uh after a year but if the uh
board were to vote to continue to
maintain the cealing of those records
the language here says that vote is in
non-public session and I would also
suggest an amendment that would require
the vote to continue to seal the minutes
should also be done in a public
session again the discussion around
whether or not to seal the minutes or to
continue to seal the minutes would occur
in non-public but the actual vote of
cealing minutes in all instances should
be done in a public session so that we
can have the utmost transparency of how
our elected officials are voting on our
behalf thank you very much and I um
thank you for the opportunity to offer
testimony and I'll take any questions
represent mlan yeah thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question the
original intention of this bill as it
was presented in the last term by
understanding was
that we wanted to release all of the
provisions after one year and some of
the feedback getting at that time is
that you may have very sensitive
information that if it's just
automatically disclosed to do an
enormous amount of harm so my
understanding with the intention of this
bill was more Broad and that it wanted
to pick something that was relatively
harmless so that it would give people
the opportunity to develop the
mechanisms around that un stealing at
the end of that year so um I would just
say that if the intention is develop
mechanisms around ultimately being able
to unal more than just this one
subparagraph after a year that the
language is saying fact but if you were
looking to go and just go after you know
this targeted self paragraph then I
think what you're saying makes sense so
I guess
just the question is what do you guys
see as the intention of this legislation
is it to develop this broader mechanism
or is it to just go after this specific
subar
paragraph well I think most
appropriately that's a question for the
sponsor of the bill um if this bill was
not uh written by right to know New
Hampshire um so I would defer to rep
yoka to uh to answer that um what I
would like to add is that from our
perspective right to know New Hampshire
recognizes that there's an ongoing
problem with the fact of uh minutes
being sealed initially and then uh even
though the circumstances for sealing
those minutes at some point in the
future no longer apply and thus should
be made public uh in practice that
infrequently takes place because uh what
we find happens is you know this the
selectman or whatever the public body is
they're moving on to other business and
they're not bothering to revisit
decisions they made six months ago a
year ago uh about sealing minutes uh
that took place in the past and thus
they stay sealed forever and I I would
use this opportunity also you know as a
um you know to make mention that there
is a another bill that's going to be
discussed in another session um that
does address um keeping a list of
minutes that have been sealed so that
there's greater
visibility towards these minutes that
are going unsealed so this is a um a
step in the right direction to address
the
problem um and I hope that answers your
question okay are there any other
questions for Mr
sad if not thank you for your testimony
again today you're
welcome cell
Johnston
good afternoon again uh again Cordell
Johnston representing the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association um and I signed in in
opposition to the bill uh actually we
support part of the
bill um and I
guess opposed part of the bill the the
first thing I would say is we actually
do like section one of the bill which I
don't think any anyone has actually
talked about yet
um this would allow the consideration
not the vote but the consideration of
whether to unseal
minutes um would allow that discussion
to occur in nonpublic session and uh we
think that that's that that makes sense
I I will add and this is a this is a
technical thing um although people
always talk about sealing or unsealing
minutes the right to no
law the word the term seal the minutes
actually does not appear anywhere in RSA
91a if you if you search for the word
seal it's not in there the um the what
the language is is that minutes must be
disclosed
closed non-public minuts must be
disclosed unless the board votes not to
disclose them so I would actually in
section one
on line three rather than say
consideration of whether to unseal
minutes I would say consideration of
whether to dis minutes um that's a
that's a technical point but I think
it's I think we ought to have the
language
consistent as far as uh what most of the
discussion has
been uh we are concerned
about uh just selecting one category of
of sealed
minutes uh and subjecting them to to an
arbitrary timeline after which they
would automatically be
unsealed I if I if I understood the
suggestion made made by David sad from
right to know Hampshire if I understand
his suggestion
correctly I think I like it better which
is that they would be automatically
unsealed and I think the language was
something like
um upon um upon closing or contract
finalization or something like
that I don't think they should I don't
think they should be automatically
unsealed just because a contract has
been signed because as we all know a
contract can fall apart uh if there's a
condition that fails to occur or
whatever but if the transaction has
actually closed then uh except in very
unusual circumstances there would be no
reason to keep the
minutes uh sealed so you know I although
although really we would like to we'd be
happy to see the law stay as it is is if
there is a proposal to have them be
automatically
unsealed uh once the transaction has
actually
closed um I think I think we could live
with that and that would make some sense
so long as there Remains the opportunity
for the for the board
to conclude uh to to vote not to
disclose them if for some reason that I
can't imagine
that would actually uh render the action
invalid so I guess I'd be interested in
seeing seeing that Amendment uh and that
may be a way to to uh get
to get to an agreement on
this thank you are there questions for
Mr
Johnston see thank you MRN app testimony
is there anyone else who is it in
attendance who would like to
testify seeing none I would note that
there were other people who signed up in
support or
opposition in support was Carla gy Lewis
kit
clitz Eric
Ren representative
plaz and representative s
and signing up in opposition where Julie
Gilman elected official from ex and
Christina Barrett from the New Hampshire
School Board
Association
and seeing no other business with regard
to the bill I'll close the hearing on
House Bill
566 and that includes our official
business
today I have uh I have lined out a
schedule of hearings for the next three
Tuesdays and uh I've been reviewing them
with the vice chair just to make sure
that I haven't gone
overboard uh so uh but I will get those
out to everybody this week so you'll
have them prior to get into the calendar
as
well is there any other business
anything I just wanted to let you know I
clarify with the speaker's office that
during
exing the entir okay I don't know if
everybody heard that but during when we
are in exec session the cameras have to
be on during the entire period of the
exec
session and any other
business we're going to check on the
issue of whether or not we need a roll
call vote to come out at the exec I
don't sex session because that's your
prerogative and
then it would be easier but I'll clarify
[Music]
that I'm sure
that let Services know or the ass know
when you're going here phally they will
you our paper roll
CS we can't hear I can't
hear the we representative rice was just
indicating that representative wber as
clerk uh would be able to
obtain uh paper roll call sheets to use
rather than having to use the computer
might make
happen more
quickly and with that unless there's
anything else just want to thank you
again everybody for being patient this
was our first hearing I think it went
pretty well today and uh that's a credit
to all of you for doing
that much appreciated and we'll look
forward to seeing you at at N9 o'clock
next
Tuesday and thank you very much Mr
ch
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr chair
thank
you bye Everybody
by bye
everyone my phone is all the way up at
9% bye everyone
bye are you going back to the office no
I'm
I yeah it's supposed to start like
around four so I kind of wanted to get
home before that really yeah how much I
don't know but I had people posting out
tomorrow I think it's one
[Music]
Orest that's
you walk
the
there hi representative McLean and
representative Gordon it's Jen I just
wanted to let you know that Pam is gonna
come by and turn off the sound in the
room and I'm going to go ahead and shut
off the meeting for you thank you
thanks how you guys thanks so